Recording to server.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan's dot net and
click on the link and enter in the code
name Rogan, you will get,
that might be me. Yeah,
you poops. You, if you click on the
link and during the code name Rogan,
you'll get 15% off the
number one sex toys for men,
so go get on that if you needed.
Good. I love that. We continue to do.
I'm like, fuck it. If you
had any doubts whatsoever,
if I'm interested in selling
out and you go take your money.
[inaudible]
Zam brothers and sisters were going
to go on a journey today. All right.
We're back from the journey
back from Las Vegas. Well, a,
I met Anthony Bordain. What am I
here? I got fucking starstruck. I met,
you know Anthony Bourdain and my
friend Yon Urban is here. Anthony,
do you watch TV at all or you just
fucking read in books all day?
I haven't had a TV turned on around
me and probably a couple of years.
Wow.
You completely out of the cultural loop
textbooks on mushrooms from the 15th.
Right. What happened? Uh,
Anthony, what'd you do?
Did you change the volume of it
was just turning it down and lunch.
She stopped doing that fucking
Weirdo. Leave that shit alone. Uh,
Anthony Bourdain's a chef and he's got
this television show. He was a chef.
Now he's pretty much like sort of this
traveling, uh, Guy, uh, who, uh, samples,
food and different restaurants
all throughout the world,
but more as like a commentator on the
cultures of these places, you know,
and uses food as sort of like a way to
get you to know the culture, you know,
uses like eating with indigenous people
and he's like tribes and weird fucking
crazy places.
I mean,
it's a bad ass fucking show
interest and it's my favorite show.
And so I met him and you know,
just of just no one, some just,
it's the weirdest fucking thing when you
admire someone and you liked their work
and they know who you
are too, you know, and,
and all of a sudden you're talking about
stuff and he came to my comedy show.
I'm like, it seems like it shouldn't
freak me out at this point in my life,
but I'm still like Holy Shit Anthony
Board days in the fucking audience.
Like it was, it was weird, you
know, it was, it was interesting.
He's a bad motherfucker. I uh,
I admire him very much. He's a,
one of the most interesting
guys on television, so he's
going to do the podcast.
He said he gets asked to things on
Twitter one go fuck himself and two
if you would do the Joe Rogan
podcast. So it's his words. Yeah,
he's cool as fuck dude. And his wife
is a, a phene for mixed martial arts.
His wife takes Jujitsu and Moy Thai and
they have a pattern up upper room in
their house and you know,
and she's got fucking trainers teach her
how to strangle people and Shit. Wow.
Yeah,
she's a freak dude.
She's like so like aggressively into it.
It was crazy watching like
her like fucking scream and
yell and get all excited
at the Wayans and Shit, you know? And he
sort of, it seems like he sort of a, okay,
I don't want, this is what she loves. I
will go along for the ride, but it just,
you know, I don't know if he would be into
it other than that, you know, I don't,
I dunno. Maybe I'm wrong. It didn't seem
like he was as into it as she is though.
She seemed really into it.
His wife is like a fucking
super fan. She's like on it.
It's like owning a gun. She's, she's
his gun probably. Yeah. She's shut.
Fuck you up dude. She's into it, man.
Yeah. He like tweeted once, you know,
I think her name was Octavia activity
of Bordain choked out or trainer.
Put them to sleep. Wow. He's
tweeting about, that's interesting.
I don't know if I could date a girl
that was more stronger and tougher and
crazier than me. You know, I need
to take control of situations.
I need to make sure I can do that.
Not like, no, I don't want to watch
whatever gay movie you want
to watch. I mean, sorry,
silly movie that you went to watch a
and then she'll just check me out. Yeah.
Wake up and you know. Well, it would
be more of a struggle than that.
I would hope he learns so
defense after awhile, son,
having tasers protect your neck.
Yeah. I think that's a weird dynamic,
man. When the girl can kick your
ass. I don't think I'd be into that.
But you know what? Some people
are, everybody's different man,
and he's obviously not in the physical
fitness and, and he's a wild dude.
Won't take some chances. He'll
rod that crazy snake. Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
He'll jump on that IOWASCA
snake and go for a ride.
But he's in the best pussy
eater. You think so? Yeah.
And this is just a champion because
he's so into, I mean that's his job.
I'm the best eater in the rural, well,
he's more of a cook than it eats.
Like the best eater would be that man
versus food guy who just eats piles of
shitty food every week or used to
it, doesn't he not eat anymore? Yeah.
That's what a Bert
Kreischer was telling us,
or are we not supposed to say it was
always that, oh wait, I've already,
we've already started showing it,
but he doesn't do the stunts
anymore because it's fucking
body was falling apart
because it's poor guys eating,
you know,
20 pounds cheeseburgers every
night while they're filming.
And you know what I mean?
He's,
he's ridiculous food challenges where
he would have to eat like, you know,
in some insane amounts of
food. Right. Yeah. I mean, I
wouldn't ever really watched,
I saw clips. I wonder if it's that, or if
he's just dating a girl. She's like, well,
my guy to getting so fat. And he's
like, you know what I mean? Like, dude,
you can't control that. How could you
possibly eat that much food? Yeah.
It's, yeah, it's terrible for you. But
you know, getting fat is really unhealthy.
Yeah. You know, I mean, you've been
fat and you've been skinny, you know,
don't you feel way better when
you're skinning? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. But I also like eating,
you know, I was, you know,
I was thinking about that the other
day. I was like, you know what?
When I was in a hardcore diet,
I made sure I only ate certain
kinds of food. You know,
like I would only eat like chickens
and and salads and stuff like that.
But then I was like, you know
what? If I wanted to Lasagna,
I couldn't have lasagna. You know?
To me it's like, wait a second.
You know what I mean?
I would rather be somewhere kind of in
the middle where I still eat healthy most
of the time,
but I need to fucking bad
once in a while. That was in Vegas.
That is the best fucking food.
Vegas has the best food. Well, you only
have an issue in that. You don't exercise.
If you exercise, you can still waiting
for 24 hour fitness to open up in Burbank.
It's just, it's impossible to
work out. You're so unmotivated.
All you need is one thing to be wrong.
It takes a radio, doesn't work in my car.
I'm not going to drive all the way to
the gym with no radio and they fixed my
radio. Then I'll start going to the
gym again. I agree. You will find,
I hate exercise, but if I, if I,
if I do it, I want to do it right.
I want to have a nice gym. It's so much
easier to have a gym at your disposable.
Anthony Bourdain's wife can learn Jujitsu.
You girl [inaudible] why don't you learn
something and see just the good thing
about it is, you know, what tires you
out? I've known you for what, eight years?
Yeah.
At least you know,
and you've worked with him
for eight years and you know,
Joe and Eddie were trying to get me
to train in Jujitsu eight years ago,
but I don't hang out with them
everyday. So what the fuck, dude,
you would've done it.
I would've totally done it if I
didn't have an hour and a half,
two hour drive every time. But I mean
like what the fuck is your excuse?
My knee is my biggest excuse.
We've talked about this already a
thousand times and I have a bad knee and
Jujitsu. It's all about fucking
twisting bones and bodies and you know,
and that does not seem like
it's a good idea. Like, Hey,
do I want to have knee problems
for the rest of my life?
Do I want to deal with all the fucking
bullshit that's going to come along with
doing Jujitsu? Like fucking getting
ringworm and, and all that crap,
or do I want to get a membership
at 24 hour fitness was like,
someone literally is a glass half
empty sort of fellow. You know,
there's, there's positive
benefits from these things.
It's not like there's only all these
negatives you're saying? No, no.
I'm sure if all these negatives as if
there's nothing for you to be learned
there.
I didn't have a brother growing up and
so like rolling around with a guy's still
at this, not worried
about, no, it's just like,
I don't if it was a guy versus girl
Jujitsu, I'm 100% end. I'll fuck,
fuck my knee. Who Cares? You know?
I just don't feel like rolling around on
the floor with a guy. I don't know why.
Same reason if somebody goes,
hey,
would you rather hang out with
three guys and watch sports?
Or would you rather hang out with
three girls and watch porn? Yeah,
I wouldn't have to say that. It's
sort of a learned thing, you know,
it's like an acquired
taste. Yeah, it does. It's,
I've been doing it for so long,
it's just totally normal to me,
but there's times I've thought about it.
There's Times where I'm rolling with a
guy and I know his sweat is in my mouth.
Yeah, no, no. Getting around it.
There's no getting around it.
Like if a guy like say a few are
like you're doing Nogi in, you know,
a guy's on top of you and you've got
them in half guard or something like that
and he's sweating. His chess could
easily be on your face. Yeah.
And your bold drenched with
sweat. I, if I had to do it,
I would definitely do geeky with two
comforters are wrapped around near
something. You're exchanging fluids,
you know, you're exchanging your sweat,
your moisture.
I mean they're not really exchanging,
but you're getting it on each other to
have, now it's not going internally,
but it does go into scratch
is the largest organ of the body and
shit does go right through the skin. So
it does. It does. That's why men have
to constantly worried about Matt herpes,
herpes, or real. You have to worry about
that. You have to worry about skin,
like ringworm type shit. You have to worry
about staph infections. A lot of guys,
it's dirty motherfuckers, man. Most
everybody's different. Like Ari,
they only changed their sheets like
once every month and a half, you know?
So He fucking,
he got staff.
That fucking guy would just go to
Jujitsu and then not shower. I was like,
why are you crazy? You would just roll
around with dudes and then not shower.
Why don't you just have people
just shit on you? Yeah. You know,
just to have people just piss
all over your body, you know?
Like what are you doing when you got to
clean yourself off, man? So what have you,
so you've got staff. There was, yeah,
he didn't even know he had staff.
We were playing pool and he's limping
around and I go, what's going on?
I got bit by a spider. Yeah.
Yeah. I did hear about this.
He pulls his pants up to show me the
spider bite. I'm like, dude, that is,
that looks like a staph infection and
you should go to the hospital right now.
You get a check. Like you can't just walk
around like that, but he didn't know.
He had no idea that you could actually
get something like that from exercise,
from Jujitsu,
you know,
you don't really hear about
people getting staph infections,
lessons from surgery, you know? Yeah.
Well most sports you don't get
staff like you're playing tennis,
you don't get to staff,
you know?
Yeah. Football players can get it. They
get it. Sometimes. It's tricky. It's very,
very dangerous. Very dangerous. And you
know, of course there's that, you know,
Murcia the a antibiotic resistant
staph infection that they've have now.
That's really dangerous because
you know, it's, it's a very,
very strong form of it and
it's very hard to kill.
It's from mostly from people not
taking their antibiotics correctly.
Yeah.
And what,
what I've found to one of the best things
to get rid of like a athlete's foot
and shit, which I'm sure you get
an environment like that a lot,
is a apple cider vinegar.
He rubbed that stuff on it a
couple of times and it's gone.
They say supposed to pee on your
feet too. Yeah, that works too.
My feet every faster though.
Yeah.
Yeah. Why not move? Why not? Not Bad for
you. It's not bad for you and it's a warm,
yeah, it comes from my own body. I is
it like what doesn't even leave my body?
It's one continuous stream.
It's not like it leaves, yeah.
Body at all.
It must have been about what,
2004 2005 I was living up in the mountains
and my phone starts ringing and it
was like probably one 32 o'clock
in the fucking morning. Right?
And I don't get, or I get
up and I answered the phone
and it's fucking this dude.
It's Joe and he's on the phone. He's
like, dude, I'm sick as fuck man.
I gotta be at the studio at like 6:00
AM I feel like shit. What do I do?
And I,
I tell us how it drink.
Drink a couple of glasses of your pis
and it'll make you feel better. Right.
Giggling with a finger in your
butt when you told him so.
So anyway, I'm fucking, I got it
back to bed. Right. And then, uh,
it must've been like three, three 30 in
the morning and my phone rings again.
It's fucking Joe.
This time I don't get up to answer it.
I would just fucking lie in bed and I,
and I hear the answering machine
pick up and it's Joe. He's a dude.
I gotta tell you man, I just drink
two glasses of my peers, dude.
I feel fucking great. I gotta tell
you man, I'm a peer streaker too.
If when people don't know,
this is very controversial
obviously,
but there's a thing called year in therapy
and the idea behind it is that your
body processes waste and that waste
comes out in the form of Shit.
But that also when water waste comes out,
the water that comes out of your body
is actually sterile and that there are
some sort of nutrients in it
and antibodies when you're
trying to get over colds
and things of that nature.
And so a lot of doctors say it's
utter complete total horse shit.
But people in indigenous cultures,
for instance,
who've been doing that to try to cure
diseases and illnesses for a long,
long time. Obviously modern medicine
is way better than drinking your own
piss. Well, you know what's interesting
though is in, in India, every year,
every couple of years they have a
meeting of doctors who meet up to,
to discuss the latest research
and you're in therapy. Uh,
I knew somebody who went to the doctor
in South America for a skin problem and
was told to drink their
urine. Whoa. So I, it is,
it's not, you know, it's, it's very rarest
I think, especially in the United States,
but I think in India and China and
certain places in South America,
it has been adopted.
He's been adopted by modern
medicine, adopted by freaks. Listen,
I'll try anything, man. I'll try anything.
I've been in zone healers before.
I'm like, look, I don't, every instinct
in my body is telling me this is nonsense.
But go ahead. Let me see what's up.
You know, let me see what's up. I just,
I'll listen to you. I listen to you and
maybe even just for material, you know,
maybe even I don't believe it and I just,
just in the interest of this might be
something that would be funny to talk
about on stage. I'll let you try
your Voodoo on me. But you know,
it's like nature makes things
look shocking and scary
because they're poisonous
if they want to. If, if, if you
were supposed to drink your pee,
it would taste like fucking stronger.
It doesn't taste bad at all.
Well it actually, it tastes without
what you ate that day. I mean,
if you drank a bunch of coffee and
soda pop and ate a bunch of crap food,
it's probably going to
taste pretty fucking bad.
But if you eat healthy and take
care of yourself, you know,
I've done it a few times as you know,
when I was sick and uh,
and something else that we'll
talk about later when a,
I was on mushrooms and you can recycle
your urine and it's supposed to put you
through Pluto. Right. And
it doesn't taste bad at all,
but it's very much,
dean is like people that
do it for health reasons,
they say that it enables them to monitor
their body on a regular basis of what
their intake is because they immediately
taste it and it's like, oh shit.
Well I don't want to eat that anymore.
I don't want to do that anymore.
It's like it, it's an
automatic alarm system, right?
Yeah. It doesn't taste bad
bro. It's not that bad.
I did it on the radio rather.
And uh,
there was a radio station,
no name show in San Francisco.
What it no anymore is it didn't
name was no name, Huh? Yeah.
Me and no name drank our own
p remember? Oh yeah, he drank,
he drank and he was gagging and I just
threw it down like it was nothing for God
was like, I drank my own pissed
like 10 times. Right. You know, I,
I mean I'll do it on a regular basis,
but there was a big thing
about Leo Machida in the UFC
that Leo Machida does it.
And then his father,
who was this karate masters
trained him since he was young boy.
He recycles his urine every morning,
every morning and gets up and drinks
his pig. Who the fuck knows man,
it might be bullshit. But if people
have been doing it for that long,
there might be some merit in it.
Yes. I've had people come up to me when
I've given lectures and say that they've
taken it for various, you
know, gout or leg problems and,
and pain problems and after, you
know, four to six, eight weeks there,
their problems cleared up. It's all
over their gout. He's, you know,
they would lay with for a week they
would drink like a, a small amount,
like a half a cup every,
every morning fresh, you know,
really. I would, I would try it once,
but I would definitely make sure I ate
a bunch of berries and I would just make
it good. How to cook it good.
I'd be a good chef. You know,
I don't recommend coffee before you do it.
The first thing you can really start
getting coffee for breakfast this morning.
It's just,
you know,
there was a guy who used to post on the
message board until he got to creepy and
someone bandom cause he was just,
uh, I forget what his deal was,
but he would,
he would get these girls that like
didn't have any money and they would uh,
take care of them for a little while
and eventually do like a bunch of dirty
shit to him like he was into
and write stories about this.
And one of the things he would do is make
as loads tastes disgusting as possible.
So he would talk about the,
the asparagus coffee loads
that he would name on it.
I don't remember honestly,
but I remember he made a lot of people
angry because they were like, well,
if this guy's telling the truth, he's
a real piece of shit as a human being.
And if he's just trolling like, stop,
stop making up some fucking story.
Say it's trolling, but you never know.
Who knows, man. I mean most likely, yeah,
most likely trolling. But either
way, it was really good writing.
It was compelling. I didn't like him in
his writing. I didn't like who he was,
but it was very compelling and I was like,
this is interesting. It's like this is,
it's obviously very good and very well
written because the idea behind it is
kind of gross to me that you would like
go out of your way to take some poor
woman who doesn't know what to do with
her life and she's really broke and you
forced her into, you know, doing
weird shit for you because you know,
that's how you get off and then
you write about it, you know,
like that's like you're victimizing
people and why, why are you doing that?
But not knowing whether or not it
was true or not true. You know,
choosing to look at it from the point
of view. Like maybe it's just fiction.
Maybe this guy is just into the mind of
a creep. You know, who knows, who knows?
But it's really well written,
but he was all into just gross loads
is apparently a recipe.
Joe Diaz will tell you how to make
it come out like shotguns. Uh,
I, yeah, I stay at this
horrible hotel. All right.
Last night we were in Vegas and I didn't
know it was a hotel that's next to a
strip club that we did a show at.
And uh,
I think that the guy that owns a strip
club owns the hotel and it's one of those
boutique hotels where you walk in and
there's nice paintings everywhere.
Like every room was a different theme
of painting and I were really cool.
But after six o'clock,
it turns into a nightclub that ope that's
open til like 8:00 AM and it's just
the gay,
the gay people,
the ravers 6:00 AM 8:00 AM it
goes about NATO, what times?
It starts at 6:00 PM 6:00 PM so we, we
got back to the hotel and there was like,
you know,
lines of people getting into the hotel
and the red rope and they're like,
you have to wait in line. I'm like, no,
we're staying here in, they're like, oh,
go through. We could want in the
whole lobby is a rave. And I'm like,
what the fuck is this place?
So we go upstairs and then looking out
the window and it was one of those views
where it's like you're just
looking at air conditioning units.
Like it's the roof,
but there's just people that were sneaking
in through like this air conditioning
unit and going up there and doing like
crazy drugs and having sex right outside
your window. And then I'm thinking, wow,
sneaking in through the air conditioning
unit. What do you mean there was doors,
there was a door going through the floor
and they were climbing out and like all
these people are hanging out on the roof
outside of our window. It was fucked up.
And then I'm looking at him like these
beds were PR are probably just made for
having sex with hookers and the process
in like strippers that are coming from
the Strip club,
you know?
And so there's that red pillow that's
a was on the bed was like one of those
fashion pills that you throw on the
ground. You don't really sleep on.
There is this come all over it
dude. And then, and then, uh,
the, the, the channels, the TV, cause
we were on shrooms, so we were like,
just trying to watch TV and you
can't hear anything except, you know,
like whole time turn on the TV
and it was just scrambled porn.
Like you straight on anal sex pops
up on your TV and you're like,
what the fuck minute scrambled.
It was a scramble it and it was,
it was channels were porn and then it's
tons of scrambled porn mixed in like
you'd go to a channel,
it's just like what is going on in that?
And then it would be like NBC and
then suddenly scrambled porn channel.
Fucking weird. Then all the lights
just turned off and turned into,
explained that it was porn and then
it would, it would go to NBC. Yeah.
Like the channels were mixed up
with porn and then scrambled porn.
So you'd whatever channel you would watch,
porn would just invade the champ. No,
no, no, no, no, no. Like, like you turn to
NBC and you turn it to the next channel.
It'll be a guy getting his
ass hole licked by a girl.
There's not porn on NBC. No, no,
no, no. Okay. Then there was,
it sounded like you remember scrambled
porn back in the day where it's just a
bunch of static.
Yeah.
You go to a hotel room and they would
have like pay per view channels and you
could click on it and you wouldn't be
able to see any doors kinds of that.
It was, it was so weird and then
the lights didn't turn on and off.
They turn on and off when you
wanted to and they were like, yeah,
this is an eco friendly
hotel where you put your key
in and it controls the air
conditioning and the lights,
which means the air conditioning didn't
work and all the lights were just
flashing on and off whenever they
want it to. And then the, the,
the pool area, topless ploy area, but
like 90% of the girls where you're like,
Holy Shit, I have your chest than her.
Or, I mean she has a Harrier tested me.
It was fucking the worst hotel in
the history of hotels, but it was
for the time we, the worst hotel you got
out alive. Here's some hotels in Russia,
but stitches where your liver,
he used to be, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
It sounds like the hotel,
it was crazy.
It was one of those hotels where they
like some of the fashion of the room was
these like little mirrors that were
placed everywhere on the wall and you're
sitting there thinking, I wonder if this
cameras underneath all those mirrors,
you know, like it seemed that sketchy.
Like what the fuck is it? Very easily.
Very easily.
If it's owned by that Strip club too.
Yeah. Wow. Ooh.
I remember that one guy, there was a guy
who got caught and he was some really,
really famous rich guy. Not A,
not a fit and famous rich guy,
but a famous rich guys son. I don't
remember the guy's name. But anyway,
they found all these fucking
cameras in his house.
Like this guy had his house like set up
as basically like a little film studio
and everything was hidden cameras and
just hundreds of videos of him just with
these drugged up checks,
it would come in stumbling in and
not knowing what the fuck, you know,
he put something in there,
drag or something. And then
he was filming all of it.
Do you remember that story?
Yeah, I do. I haven't combined two
stories. How long? I don't know.
I remember that though. Like he found
shit, like his phones were all tapped.
There was cameras in everywhere.
Like in his lights and everything.
No, no, no, no. This guy did
it on purpose. He set up his
room, his bedroom like that.
And then they suspected
them of drugging checks.
I was thinking of a story
where a guy found out that he,
his whole house was bugged anything.
So that was the government and
it was from like three years ago.
I can't remember.
Who Cares?
Well, there was that Hemingway
thing. It's just came out, you know,
Hemingway thought that the government
was following him and it turns out their
war. They were tablets, phones,
they were following him.
So he was right and it was
like what they say, you know,
some people say the,
the last straw that drove Hemingway
to commit suicide and that he was a,
people thought he was just paranoid
but in fact the government really was
watching him. Like why the fuck would
you be watching a writer? You know,
like what do you know?
The idea I guess is that he was too
close to the communist or something like
that. Cause he was
always in Cuba. You know,
he was just fucking to overthrow
the government or something.
Just being a bad ass being Hemingway.
Yeah. You know, there was so much
intelligence going on on different levels.
You had this whole dialectic
between communism and
capitalism on one level being
steered by bankers higher up.
But all of this stuff,
you know,
that goes into a lot of my current
research right now. In fact,
I've got council on foreign relations
documents sitting right here next to me
from them talking about mushrooms,
stuff like that. You know,
these are the key players in the
council on foreign relations.
People are in a crazy stuff on
so many levels, you know? Yeah.
And you were messing up people's heads
and the CIA messing with people's heads.
Mk Ultra,
they've been,
they've been spying on people and mess
with people forever. Of course. Yeah.
And you,
you would,
you would have to think that anyone with
any level of intelligence who is in any
position of power would want to know
about chemicals to change people's minds.
He'd want to know about it. You know,
you, you, you wouldn't just ignore it.
You wouldn't just say, oh,
we need to make this illegal.
They would start looking into some things.
There's no way they have,
it would be crazy not to.
Well,
interestingly,
what I've found out recently is that there
was this exclusive club that a lot of
these elitists and bankers and
intelligence people belonged to,
and they would share the information
on psychedelics at the highest levels.
I mean,
pretty much everybody at the highest
levels from the 1940s through the 60s knew
what was going on about psychedelics
on every level before the public did.
And, uh, yeah,
I would think they'd have to,
I don't know how you could be any position
in any position of power and not be
aware of something that powerful.
Something that's, you know,
like the whole movement of the 60s and
whether people want to wrap their head
around it or not. That was all
drugs. That whole, you know,
that whole acid culture that was coming
out of San Francisco, that whole,
that whole summer of love, that,
that, that generational gap,
that huge leap between the 1950s
and 1960s that was all drugs, man.
There was all drugs.
It was all people smoking pot and people
doing heroin and people, you know,
getting high on mushrooms and acid and
feeling things that they had never felt
before and being able to express things
in a way they never felt before and the
disenfranchised every fucking
generation filled disenfranchise man.
There's no getting around that.
It's impossible to get around it.
Everybody wants to escape from
their fucking parents. Clutches.
Everybody wants to escape from the
designs of a system that's they've been
thrust into.
You know,
you've been born into this fucking
system that you have to participate in
without you having any say
in it whatsoever. Just boom.
Every fucking single
generation feels like that.
But that generation
got ahold of some shit.
Well, you know, lawsuit. And the
interesting thing, you know, and,
and here I've got literally
a stack of stuff right here.
This is all council on foreign. We're
going to go through that in a podcast.
Mr Oh, I'm just showing you guys,
we're not going to go through it,
but there is some serious stuff right
here that shows how top members of US
intelligence like Allen Dulles,
John Foster, Dulles, uh,
Bank bankers like,
uh,
frank [inaudible] and other
guys like Walter Lippmann,
all of these intelligence people as well.
We're at the highest levels
involved in all of the psychedelics.
I all idea guys knew it. I have no idea
who any of those people Alan Gomes was.
Hold on, let me see if theorists out
there, I'll know who Allen Dulles is.
I have no idea any of those people are.
But I do think that if I was like a total
like Internet conspiracy Geek and he
just hit me with all those names in a row,
I would have the Uber obscure
named Guy Hard on right now.
Those right now get the fuck out of those.
I was thinking about all those documents.
Don't they haven't like
in pdf form now you can.
You can just have him like I have
all these documents on my phone.
Think right here is eight gigs and the
only reasons why it's eight gigs because
the 16 gig ones for some reason that
they don't process well with our,
our little MP three recorder.
We don't need your crazy papers.
Your stacks of nonsense.
The problem with that is we don't
believe it and that's the top paper man.
If it's digital,
you can do anything digital shit.
We can do anything to paper ship to the
age of knowing what the fuck anything is
is over.
Those days are done man.
You're not going to know what's real
and what's not real anymore. It's just,
it's going to be, it's too tricky. There's
two pictures of Megan Fox getting fun,
have a systematic method of figuring
shit out anymore. That's the big problem.
That is a problem.
But the other problem is the ability
to manipulate information, Matt matter.
It's just too, if you have a
systematic method of filtering it,
then you know how to spot bullshit
right away. You know it's, it's, yeah,
maybe there is, there is a way
to do it. Actually there's,
there's experience and instincts too.
You know,
there's certain times when
you look at something,
Brian's pretty good at spotting a
internet meme sort of bullshit. Right?
Well you got it. You nailed them. I
say you had all the people that I know,
you probably have the highest success
rate for nailing Internet meme.
I think I'm pretty good at with
it in life to just meeting people,
judging people.
I'm,
I overthink everything and try to
like play out all these different,
same area. If you guys ever
studied logical fallacies,
no.
That gets really good because it shows
you exactly how people lie and then
enables you to name the
exact lie that they're using.
So it gives you explicit knowledge.
So like if somebody uses
an ad hominem worker,
an attack on the man right there,
let's say you say something,
you make a claim and they
say, oh, well Brian's a fag.
I don't want to listen to anything.
He says, well then you know, oh,
well that's an ad hominem.
He didn't deal with the
information that Brian presented.
He attacked Brian instead. There's
all of these network. Exactly. No,
there's all these new macro fallacies.
So you, when you can name them though,
it totally enables you how to,
to know when somebody's lying to you.
And so when you can understand that.
See, now I have like this
energy thing where I think it's,
I really think it's mushrooms are soggy
psychedelics that it's kind of enhance
this,
that I could actually look at people and
kind of hear him talk and look at their
eyes and face and not actually study it.
Just an overall,
I could feel they're kind of like an
energy almost like I can see if this
person's a little dark in places
and kind of like, it's weird.
It's true. There's certain people
that you're not going to feel yes.
It's a sociopath. Yeah. Have you ever
had a sociopath snip a new circle and
you didn't realize he was a sociopath
until like after a while you're like,
Whoa, what the fuck is going? You know,
Eddie Bravo and I knew I'd do to kill
the guy. Yeah, I haven't had that,
you know that story. Now what
happened? There was a guy his,
well he would say his name is Rafael Tory,
but that wasn't his real name.
His real name was something else.
He like invented this name and pretended
he was a Brazilian jujitsu black belt
and made his way into the mixed martial
arts community as a total scam artist.
And uh,
Eddie had disowned him for lying about
jujitsu cause Eddie found out that he
lied about being a black belt.
He wasn't really a black belt at all.
So Eddie like stop hanging out with
him cause he's like, this guy's crazy.
He's just making things up.
Like he had rolled them a couple of
times and tapped him out really easy.
But then he thought maybe the guy was
like being respectful and not trying to
roll too hard. But then he
realized after a while I go, no,
this guy is terrible cause he's not,
he doesn't know any Jujitsu.
He's not black belt. This is
crazy. Anyway, time goes on.
That guy killed a guy and uh,
he was dating this guy's wife and Lord,
this guy back to his dojo apparently,
and choke the guy to death. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. That's deep shit.
Killed The guy and then was driving
around the dude's car and shit.
So I knew that guy, man.
I hung out with that guy.
I hung out with that guy and his wife.
Wow. Yeah. They were over at Eddie's.
And you had no,
no feeling at all,
feeling of danger or any
feeling that he was a bad guy.
He seemed like just a friendly dude.
Just, he hadn't killed anybody yet.
I don't think. I mean maybe did
it earlier and got away with it.
I don't think maybe the
posting was so good.
Maybe it was just so good.
He just couldn't help it.
I don't know. I doubt it.
But he was already getting it. I
don't get the killing part. Yeah.
How about you just moved to Florida
together or something crazy.
We don't have to fucking kill that guy
man. Go halfsies on Costco memberships.
You don't be crazy.
But I think I like to think that I have
the ability to spot bullshit and I think
I'm pretty good at it. But thank God
it troubles me. That got troubles me,
the idea that you know that I ran into
that guy and had no idea that he was
capable of murder because I've met some
other people and if you ask me if they
are capable of murder I
would say yeah probably.
This is funny cause like,
you know, Dunkin is,
would you ever think that Dunkin could
be one of those guys that go off and go
crazy murder people?
Duncan can murder somebody.
She was correct because I was looking at,
if I haven't seen could,
if you had your life, that danger, if
you saw it, you know, everybody could,
if you were pushed to a position
where you felt like you had to,
I Love Dunkin a death. But, but
he, that the thoughts that he has,
and especially when he was in that satanic
mode, I was like, really? Is He? Like,
I always wondered, oh, well he's
just experimental. You know,
when he was in the Satanism,
he was just being experimental.
He wasn't really like, I'm gonna
fucking worships Satan. He was like,
I think it's fascinating that everybody
misunderstands this and what it really
is, is there, they're saying they want
to be hedonistic, you know, they want to,
you know, indulge and pleasures and
overeat and have sex and sleep till noon.
Like that's like,
that's satanism to
them,
that's like expressing themselves in the
most ridiculous and outrageous and self
serving way possible as opposed
to this idea of, you know,
the pious Christian who's trying
to serve the Holy Father. Well,
you have his fascination with serial
killers too, which is amazing.
He does. Yeah. Yeah. There is
another level to satanism. They,
you should check out to mark pass.
He was work those interested.
He goes into some deep stuff.
He used to be at a priest of
the Church of Satan Dunkin.
Like all artists toys with
madness. You know, everybody does.
He does it to the most. I that I know.
That's why I would think I agree. I agree.
He, he's, he gets, he
gets deep. He wants, well,
he's very experimental with
his thought process is,
it's one of the reasons why it's comedy
so funny and that uh, you know, his,
just his sense of the world.
This is very unique. I love it.
It's a very fascinating take,
but it's a couple steps away from crazy.
I know. It really is. And it's as it is
mine, you know, I am guilty as charged,
you know, when people say it would be
human, they're like, dude, there's no,
you're never going to get out
of me than I think in any way,
shape or form that I'm some
sort of a perfect person.
I'm constantly fucking up left and right,
trying to patch up mistakes,
trying to fucking be on the straight
and narrow all the time. But uh,
I'm crazy too. I know, I know. Given the
right circumstances, the right situation,
I could go fucking completely insane.
And I think a lot of artists are in that
same situation. You know, you, you, you,
you know, if everything's going smooth in
your life, you don't even know yourself.
You don't know what you're capable of.
It's when the shit gets ugly that you
find out what you're really capable of.
You know like Donner Party start type
shit where people freeze and you got to
eat them.
You don't want to start with you first
meet somebody, Bro. I'm getting that ass.
Snap is his ass is mine.
I'll go way over to the dark side up
well over some burning sticks because
there's so much fat in
his meat. He would, yeah,
that would be the be delicious pecan.
Yet you might be the best.
So you're like a fail. I don't know.
I feel like a Chubby, very hairy.
I think it would have a lot of roots.
So it was a pig bro, but a delicious,
once you burn that hair off.
Come on son. Come on son.
I'm black so don't get crazy.
Oh,
so young.
You wrote two books on psychedelics
and their relationship to Christianity.
You've got the first one that you wrote
was the farm aquatic inquisition. Well,
that was the DVD I did
from Pharma aquatic quick,
the quack in there and I see that, yeah.
Asked for theology and shamanism was,
that was the book,
right?
So the Pharma cratic inquisition was what
you were going to call it at one point
in time and then you decided to
just do it as a lecture series.
Right. Well, you know, it just
asked her theology in shamanism.
Describe more of what the book
is about, which is the, well, we,
we published ancient primary texts
about ancient son and star worship and
Christianity.
And we've also published a more recently
ancient primary texts on Christian's
using mushrooms as well, which is
what, uh, my second book is about.
And that's the holy month.
That's the holy mushroom evidence
of mushrooms in Judeo Christianity.
But in that book, I published
the first ancient, uh,
primary texts of mushroom
use by Christians.
And it was a document called the
epistle to the renegade bishops,
which is a Canaanite text
for the, uh, Orthodox church.
You know what I love about yawn
before you go any further? I met,
I met Jaan years ago. I mean, how long ago
have I known you? At least eight years.
At least eight years.
And when I met Jaan years ago,
he was just this really cool guy. I met
you over a Jack Harris House, right?
We got to Jackson.
Yeah,
we went to Jack Harris House and yon
was just this really cool guy who was a
very smart and had a lot of information.
But there's a lot of those guys,
you know,
and they'll tell you things,
they'll tell you stuff about this and
did you know that the 15th president,
Blah Blah Blah. And then you
know the fascinating to talk to,
but you actually wrote fucking books.
You know what I'm saying?
Like my man wrote some real ass books,
you know,
with like references and you know,
banner photos got a glossary in this
bitch. You know, there's photographs,
the color photos are fucking awesome
because it's like at a certain point in
time it becomes undeniable.
And that shirt,
the shirt that you have on that is
a cardinal. Anybody can see that.
It shows the color cardinal
and how the cardinals, well,
you know the, the ancient Catholic Church
period, the ancient Christianity was,
they were obsessed with that mushroom.
Either miscarry a mushroom or you
got it over there. Hold up the,
hold up the front cover
of the holy mushroom book.
It's hard to see because this is
a really old painting and it's uh,
when you're,
when you're looking at it,
let me, let me tell him
what it is though. On the,
on the right side of the window there,
up above his baby Jesus riding on the
back of Saint Christopher and baby Jesus
is in the shape of a mushroom.
And we've even had a,
a professor of my Qology identify the
exact type of mushroom that Jesus is
depicted as there.
And that's from a month Ferran de
Perigord France from the 13th century,
from a chapel there.
And there's a lot of mushrooms
on this fucking wall.
So most artists are drug addicts.
So wouldn't you think back then that
artist they did. It was just like, man,
I'd like to get some mushrooms
and I got hired to do this. Church
is with the mushroom.
Let you know if you think about it,
he probably got a lot of trouble
for that. Right. That's got stoned.
They ain't got,
a lot of people are probably like,
what the fuck Christian Jews and
mushrooms. What's that about? You know,
imagine if this whole Christian mushroom
connection was really just a bunch of
taggers. I seriously, I just
jokesters who were already as well.
We actually do have several
primary texts about it. In fact,
there's one text found in the Jewish
Kabbalah and the book is Zahar.
This specifically discusses the mushroom,
the red mushroom or the red fungus
actually. And uh, like I said,
the Christian texts, the epistle,
the ring renegade bishops,
there's a Muslim texts
from, from this, uh,
from the seventh century that discusses
Manna being a type of mushroom.
And Mana was, uh, referred to in
other texts as well, and Soma and
was referred to in the Hindu text.
And that was also thought to be
possibly related to her. Right, right.
And that there is an argument right
now going on between academics.
If the Mana that where it says that
it's a mushroom in this Muslim mish cat
text,
if it's talking about a truffle or a
psychedelic mushroom and the word there
that they use it,
you know,
it describes the word site
and the word site that they,
that is written in the original text
can be spiritual or visual site.
So they're,
the debate is whether or not this
truffle is a mushroom mushroom or a or a
truffle type mushrooms. So,
you know, but uh, either way,
Matt Maana, Manna appears to have
been a type of mushroom, but you know,
I have to give John Market
will they grow credit?
I am the publisher of the 40th
anniversary edition of his book.
And this book here was actually
a really famous book and the uh,
we've taught a 1970. Yeah, we've talked
about this many times on the show.
I republish that a little book.
Well this is the new version that you guys
published. Yeah, I republished it. Yeah.
I work with Gianna lagers, family and
two copies of the old original one. Yeah,
I've got a couple.
I bonded to buy them because I knew
they were out of print and there were so
it's so great. It was, uh,
the new version has a 35 page addendum
by Professor Carl Rock from Boston
University who has come out publicly
endorsing the lagers work, you know,
and then plus,
like I said,
my back's it though any further
because there's a lot of people who are
uninitiated. All right. Ma.
John Marco Allegro law worked for the
people that were deciphered the dead.
So he was one of the original eight
members of the Dead Sea Scrolls team to
translate the Dead Sea Scrolls. They,
they contacted Oxford University.
He was studying for the, his
doctorate in philology there, uh, in,
uh, Asiatic languages, which
the, that part of the Middle
East is considered Asia.
And uh, so he, that somebody,
somebody contacted the university
and asked them to send their best.
So they recommended John Allegro ago and
so he worked to translate the Dead Sea
scrolls from 1953 until 1968.
He was actually the only member of the
tribe of the Dead Sea scrolls scrolls
team to ever release any information
about the Dead Sea scrolls to the public
during the,
uh,
that period from like 1953 until 1991.
And, uh, so he,
the other members of the team sat on
their information for years and after a
huge blow up the Huntington
Library and about 1990 91,
which is over by Pasadena,
uh,
they finally released all
of their photographs and
their possession of the Dead
Sea Scrolls,
which finally allowed other scholars to
get their hands on them and translate
them. But John Allegro,
up until that point,
was the only one that was fighting
against the rest of the team to put
information out. And of
course, they attacked him.
If you've got a dead sea
scrolls displays today,
they almost completely omit them from any
mention of a, of the Dead Sea Scrolls.
But he was really the key player
to get it out to the public.
And so in, um, well what
happened was in the,
in the 1950s, Pr, uh,
professor John Rams bottom from the
London Botanical Museum published a book
suggesting that and Adam and eve and the,
and the,
and the tree of knowledge was a mushroom
and he showed a fresco from France,
from, it's called the Plain Crow
Fresco. That's how can people find,
what is it called? The Plain Crow Fresco
and spell that's in the book there.
Image number here because it's a
fascinating image. Let me see that. Uh,
just hold up the back of the book.
They're actually,
the problem is that most people are
not going to see this. This is wrong.
Most people are going to get this on
Sirius satellite radio or on iTunes. Yeah,
but it's p l a I.
N c O. U. R. A. U. L. T. Say
that again brother. I was
talking over you. I'm sorry.
P L A I. N C. O. U. R. A. U. L. T.
And let me check that again.
The painting is amazing if you
haven't seen it before. And again,
Brian could be right, it could be some
crazy artist who's really into mushrooms.
Well that's what most artists are into.
You know,
we'll take it out like
that's why they're painting.
I've never heard that point before.
It's very, it's a very good point.
I know every artist and every
author like to do drugs there.
They're taking these scrolls or Deaton.
These guys probably did a lot drugs and
they were throwing mushrooms in also
like that. You were talking
about that maze or whatever.
It's called the maze mushroom early.
Earlier.
What was the mice from that
you're calling earlier? Uh,
you said it was from the old
Hebrew text when you translate it.
They said they called mom. Yeah. Yeah.
So maybe the author of, you know,
cause of that was on my
shoulders to the camera.
Throw some mushrooms in here
cause I like to eat mushrooms too.
Throwing it
in my holy mushroom book,
I published 43 images are paintings
that that go from Russia to England,
and it shows a pretty
widespread use from the early
first millennium all the way through
the 1890 [inaudible] or late 1800
[inaudible].
So as of God hired someone to write
the Bible, and as they do is write me,
just draw some mushroom. She's like, yeah,
of course he's going to tag
the Bible if God, God Pagan,
gods busy, he has other things except for
looking through deciphering mushrooms.
Back to this John Mark old allegro thing.
So John Mark Fro Allegro,
working in the Dead Sea
Scrolls for 1415 years. He,
he comes to the conclusion with this
book that you are republishing the Sacred
Mushroom, the cross, right? And if you
allow me, if, tell me if it's correct,
his conclusion is that all of Christianity
is a gigantic misunderstanding of
what it really,
what it really is about is the
fertility calls and the consumption of
psychedelic mushroom, right?
And that's the whole religion.
He argues that Jesus himself
was an anthropomorphism,
are a metaphor for the mushroom,
for the entheogenic experience itself,
not a physical person. And
in fact, uh, theologists and,
uh,
religious experts still today are a
debate constantly whether or not Jesus and
these characters were a historical,
uh,
there's a lot of evidence to suggest that
they are in fact myths just like Zeus
or any of the Greek gods or, or, you know,
any of the Hindu gods or any
other gods. Um, so, but you know,
when you live in your own religion
and you have your own beliefs,
you tend to take them on as
real historical characters.
But as I showed him my first book
asked with theology in Shamanism,
when you compare all of these different
religions that hold beliefs like a sun,
worship and moon worship in these
things as well as psychedelics,
and they all start to tie together,
when you look at their similarities
through a fertility rituals,
through psychedelic use and through Sun
and star and moon worship. You know,
like I said earlier, I published
a, a fourth century, uh,
texts from father epiphanies where he's
sitting there talking about how, uh,
the birth of Jesus coincides exactly
with the birth of the sun and everything.
And then he says,
but all of those other pagan religions,
they're not the real one.
We're the real one.
And his text was actually censored for
a thousand years by the church until
another, uh, older copy of it was
later found and published in the 1850s.
So they, you know, the church literally
tried to suppress one of their own guys,
text talking about this stuff.
Well,
I would assume that if you,
if you look at all this religious artwork
that has all these mushrooms symbols
in them, and we're talking about
doorway openings, right, like the,
the shape of doorway openings and Jack
Herer when he was about to write the
Sriracha, open up Astra theology and
shamanism and show him some of the door
to just audio because like I said,
the majority,
the vast majority of the people that
get this podcast get adjusted. Yeah,
that's right. All right. But,
um, anyway, what my point was,
do you think that how it went down
was that all of this knowledge and
information about psychedelics
was kept from the common person?
Was it like only with the
powers of the church? Was it? It
was, it was kept with, it
was kept for the elite.
Those who basically have the knowledge
of the trivium and quadrivium or had
studied the seven liberal arts,
they were considered better than the,
than the masses or the dead as they're
also known are the profane. Right.
And so the elites in the educated
withhold this information for themselves,
the trivium and quadrivium, the
psychedelics, the history of philosophy.
There's actually,
there's also that a lot of people don't
know about is there was this ancient
conversation.
It's 2,500 years old.
It's still going on and it's called a,
it was called the great conversation,
but it's found in a series of books called
the great books of the Western World
and, uh, leading thinkers
and leading experts.
Every generation add on to
this great conversation.
And it's still going on today. It goes
all the way from Socrates to today.
And a right now it's like 54 or
59 volumes or something like that.
It's like a tenure undertaking.
But any real expert in the
ancient knowledge or in
philosophy or anything like
that is studied this, this great
conversation or has participated in it.
And so there's all of these
different levels of knowledge.
The trivium and quadrivium
is the foundation to the
great books of the Western
world. So you have to have
a firm understanding of of
this information like the,
and all of this is related
to the religions as well.
But just to give a very quick synopsis,
the trivium specifically
in this order is grammar,
logic and rhetoric and that teaches
you how to think and how to learn,
not what to think. And then the
quadrivium is math, geometry,
music and astronomy specifically
in that order. Math is number in,
uh, math is number, math,
geometry is number in space.
Music has number in time. And astronomy
is number and music and time. And then,
so when you have this foundation is number
and music and number number in space
and time. Music is number
and time. Astronomy is number
in space and time. Okay,
sorry about that. So if this
motherfucker, I need a calculator,
but what they, what they do is,
you know, up until the 1850s,
everybody in their schooling was
taught the trivium and quadrivium.
So then if you wanted to go on to this
higher level of education in the great
books of the Western world,
you could participate.
But all of the old grade thinkers were,
were in on it basically.
So all the old great thinkers
were in on mushrooms. But no,
well not necessarily in on the mushrooms.
They were in on the great conversation.
But there are aspects and you know,
in my research and in some of these
documents here through some of the clubs,
it's very clear that that,
uh, many members of the elite,
like let's say the owner of time
life magazine, the head of the CIA,
uh, rich finance, here's
like Oppenheimer or,
or Walter Lippmann or, or,
uh, uh, uh, frank asphalt,
these guys geek boner right now.
Right?
All of these guys were in on this top
knowledge and they were sharing this
information at the top levels.
I can actually,
you know I have documentation that
actually these are from university life,
from the CFR archives at at Princeton
University and things like that.
So I can show you from their
own archives and their archives.
They talk about mushrooms,
they talk about psychedelic drugs.
The key players involved,
like especially Gordon Wasson,
the Gordon Wasson was involved in all
levels of US intelligence and he is the
guy who in 1957 brought out the story
about magic mushrooms and light and
magazine magazine. Bright
and very famous art. Right.
So really sending Gordon Wasson was
a chairman for the council on Foreign
Relations, right? Henry Luce at time
life magazine. He was and bones,
but he was also working with,
with Gordon Wasson ads.
This is what I want to see a our,
this is what I wanted to avoid because
this is whenever I talked to Yon,
he has to go so deep
what all this shit and
I'm sure it's all real. Well
I'm sure it's all real. I'm,
I shouldn't say conspiracy.
He conspired,
they conspired to do something and do
they have the documents that show that?
That's not interesting to me.
What's interesting to me is how this all,
what about those audiences might be
too far?
You go too far and you go too
far down to this guy, that guy,
I got to take notes on names.
I don't know. Honestly,
to me it's like you start saying all
these names and stuff and I'm still
confused because I don't know any
of the treatments or take it from an
entertainer who knows his audience and
he dropped me a wrong way to go with this
subject. Draw me a picture because
it's a fascinating subject.
The idea that all religions experiences
come from psychedelic experiences.
It totally, completely makes sense. The
connection between this Ama miscarry,
a mushroom, the relationship
that it has to Christmas trees,
you know that it has a Michael
Riser relationship with
the Christmas tree and it
grows under him, you know, and
that all of these things, these,
this is no one knows about this.
This is all for some reason
has been kept out of uh,
public school systems kept out of
universities. No, nobody's talking about,
it's all about it.
It's all being kept from
the public education system
isn't designed to make you
intelligent for your mind. It's designed
to make you a good soldier of fact.
Right. But, okay. But forget about that.
Is there a single course in any accredited
university anywhere in the world
where they go into depth about
the history of psychedelic use?
I would say yes. There are a few and
you know, and anthropology especially,
but a professor Tom Roberts
at the University of Illinois
has been teaching the
oldest running psychedelics course since
the 1980s and what does he talk about?
He makes me about psychedelic
research or as well, yeah.
He's also a major archiver of psychedelic
information and things like that.
So go into depth about like the history
of its use. Like John Mako, allegro. Yeah.
And people are allowed to, you
know, study, you know with the,
he allows his people in his class
to choose a book and the whole,
you know,
there's like four or 500 books on
psychedelic studies on from all different
directions out there and he lets
them go out and research these and,
and write reports on them.
And things like that as part of the class.
So That's interesting.
I wonder how if he gets talked to by
anybody in any point in time, you know,
and they have to make sure that he doesn't
encourage the use of these and that
it has to go through now as
I'm sure that they make it.
What do you think obvious,
but, uh, you know,
I interviewed him on my podcast for those
who don't know gnostic media.com but
gnostic is g n o s t I c media.com.
But,
uh,
he was very open about his
own psychedelic use on my show
really well is, you know, I've,
I've interviewed more than 60 doctors
and professors and leading experts in,
in psychedelic studies on
my show from Stan Grof,
who's one of the leading x or the leading
expert on Lsd and a bunch of other
people. And they're very straight
forward about their own personal use.
I think there's been one doctor that I've
had on Deborah Mash at the University
of Miami who said she's never tried
the drugs that she researches. Hmm.
That's interesting. Um, Strassman's
Kinda, he, he doesn't really
talk about it that much. Josie,
not too much. But, uh, you know,
he and I have talked about it a
little bit on the side before,
but he's not too public about anything.
Well, his, if you don't know Strassman
as the guy who wrote the book, Dmt,
the spirit molecule, which is an amazing
book. One of the more recent, uh,
probably the most recent study of,
of a,
of psychedelic drugs that was a approved
by the federal government. And He, uh,
he's shot these people up,
but DMT and they had these fucking
incredible visions and incredible stories,
like really intense book and a very,
very fascinating,
but he didn't talk about it too much,
but he did tell me about these crazy
people that have a loophole in New Mexico
and they just got away with doing this.
Apparently they just one
during the supreme, uh, with,
uh, with the Supreme Court.
You know,
the people I'm talking about,
the church that they drink
that a wasp wasp, it's not,
they call it Hawaii Oscar though you know
it, but it is a DMT and orally active.
Right. Well, you know, Paska Iowasca
there's a few different names for it,
but there, same thing, same thing.
Would you recommend [inaudible] was it,
I think that's the name of it.
And they wear,
they wear uniforms and they all take
like super powerful IOWASCA and then sing
songs about Jesus.
Right? Yeah. The Santo Daime a church,
they won the rights to practice
up in Oregon about two years ago.
And the Uno de Vegetal is another Iowasca
church that operates in the United
States and they've had approval
for about five or 10 years.
How incredible is that? Right? It's like
you have the native American church,
you have the native American church.
The Oakland way on native
American church is the only one,
only native American church that
allows non natives to practice and they
practice payoti mushrooms. They pretty
much did the whole thing there. Yeah.
And non natives are allowed, non
natives are allowed in the open of way.
How branch and that's run by uh,
James Warren,
flaming eagle. Mooney Flying
Eagle, sir. Yeah. Out there.
Let's make something happen.
I'm talking about like a yearly thing.
Holla at your boy. We could
do at legal legal, right.
Payoti the desert. You know, and when
you think about it, almost all religions,
if you go back far enough,
they were using psychedelics.
It wasn't just the native Americans of
the South Americans use Iowasca or you
know, it wasn't just the brown cultures,
it was the white culture is to, you know,
and in genesis,
Rachel and Leah are arguing over who
gets the mandrakes to have sex with a
Rachel's husband. Right? So
this is Greek. Mandrake is a, a,
is a psychedelic as well as an
aphrodisiac. It's a, in the school, Paul,
I mean family with the GSS, 10 found new
drug. Right. You know, and the, in the,
in the song of Solomon's it,
in the Song of Solomon,
it discusses mandrake
there as well. And, uh,
there's been a number of people,
myself, Jack Hair, that we both knew,
Andy Clark,
Heinrich of all argued that the entire
story in Song of Solomon is actually a,
a basically a psychedelic
story if you'd look at it.
And if the characters are put in context
of drugs and red mushrooms with white
spots and things,
suddenly the story makes a lot more sense.
Here's an example,
and it is on the same subject though.
It doesn't feel that it would be of,
uh,
you know how we were talking earlier about
being able to feel if someone's weird
feeling someone's crazy.
The first time I was introduced to the
subject was the first time I met Yawn,
Yawn over Jack Harris Place and Jack
Hara was showing me all these photos,
which I hope are still around.
I hope somebody got those.
He had these incredible photos of artwork.
We're showed naked people on the
block and all and stuff like that.
They were under a mushroom.
They had like a transparent mushroom
and they were naked in ecstasy,
dancing as the mushroom.
Clearly showing these people under
the effect of this psychedelic drug.
And so it's me and it's yon and it's
Jack and it's Jack's friend and man,
Jack's friend. All my alarms
are going off. I'm like,
this guy is just fucking weird, man. I'm
like, this guy is creeping me out. Yeah.
You know, like to wait talks. I don't
like the way he interacts with me.
I'm uncomfortable when it
gets close to me. I'm like,
how are these people around
this guy? I'm like, this guy.
Yeah. And I'm just not picking up any of
this. And you know, it's funny. It's like,
what? It must have been like six
months later, I called Joe Up,
I'm driving down the freeway one day and
I called you up and they're like, dude,
you know that guy that was at
Jack's House that day? I was all,
he just got busted.
He's all,
and then Joe interrupts me and he
said he was a pedophile and I went,
oh my fucking God. How did you know?
And he's all, I just knew dude. Right?
The guy got arrested for being,
yeah.
The guy got arrested for pedophilia
and killed himself in jail. Wow.
Or supposedly, oh no, he did.
Dude, he can set up this whole, no,
he set up this whole little
rich little ritual and oh,
when he sent a letter to my friend about
the whole ritual that he was doing,
I mean it was all like,
you know,
timed with the eclipse and all
this shit and with the pope,
with Pope John Paul's burial,
it was like,
what's his pocket with 2005 or some shit?
No. Um, I don't know. I just
knew, I knew I wanted to kill him.
When you're around certain people, when
you want to kill him, that's not good.
Like when you're,
you feel like,
you just feel like this is a
dangerous animal that's near me. Like,
why am I allowing this thing to be
near me? I did mine. I don't, you know,
like I said, I don't claim
to be perfect at this. I did.
Raphael Tory guy totally
slipped through my radar.
My mostly because I was stoned
as fuck when I was everywhere.
I was hanging around with them. Right.
Maybe it was that. Maybe it was just too,
you know,
we were just known as fuck that day at
Jack Harris household places. Good point.
Whatever it was,
this movement
me off. Yeah, it was so,
it was so uncomfortable because it was
the first time I was meeting Jack and it
was a, it was really like, you know,
if you don't know who Jack Hara is,
Jack Hara wrote the book. The emperor
was sank him, rest in peace. Jack. Um,
he wrote a book called the emperor wears
no clothes and it's a brilliant book
where it really breaks
down everything that, um,
the whole history of standing up
and marijuana and medical marijuana.
Actually,
our friend Todd McCormick has
rerelease this and they put a new one.
Just have a new edition.
I haven't even,
the Todd moved up north and I haven't any,
I don't have a new one. I still have
the old one, but it's my library,
which is in the other side of the house.
It's like,
he's like 12 autograph copies
from every edition from jacket.
He was a guy who, it's really fascinating
story. He was a Goldwater Republican,
a real man's man.
It was in the military and this guy gets
divorced and he made some woman and you
know,
I wants to get laid.
So he gets high with her and now all of
a sudden he like realizes the benefits
of marijuana and then he gets
angry and realize it. Holy Shit.
Like we're being fucked over and lied to.
Like this stuff is great.
And dedicates his life to
letting people know how amazing.
Literally the father of the
hip movement and uh, yeah,
so he actually brought industrial hemp
back to like 50 comes. That's not him.
The guy in the middle, the older
guy next to him. That guy. No, no,
no. I have photos of the child molester
guy. I have a photo of all of us together.
All of us, all of us together. You, me and
Jack and the dead child molester. Yeah,
man, I knew when you called me
up, I just knew it sounds stupid.
I mean it could have been just a great
guest and I'm all cocky like you're a
cold.
I knew it,
but I knew when I was around that
there was something wrong with them.
I knew it was so obvious to me.
I was like,
how are these mother fuckers hanging
out with this guy every now and then?
Like if that's the, the,
the danger that you run.
If you ever decide to have a party,
you know,
like one buddy will bring this one dude
that's like completely insane and you're
like, how do you not know this guy's
at the scene? You know, like there's,
there's certain people that were like,
hang out with one person who is completely
off the charts crazy and they just
accepted probably cause they grew
up with them or something. Yeah.
If you're having a party,
that motherfucker come over crashing
and that's what that guy was.
But that guy also,
besides being a complete fucking nut
and a psychopath and a child molester,
he also was like really fascinated by
the idea of Santa Claus being the Amanita
Mascara machine and the whole
history of that mushroom.
But people don't know Santa Claus was
red and white. The laminated miscarry.
A mushroom was written white Santa Claus
lives in Siberia and the North Pole,
the emoney to miscarry a mushroom
that it's, you know, used by the shot.
His favorite food is the enemy. We need
to miscarry a mushroom reindeer Caribou.
Caribou is who characters.
That's what they love to eat and they
literally will eat your pis. If you're P,
if you step outside of a showman lodge,
when you're fucking doing these
mushrooms and you piss in the snow,
they will knock you over
to eat your pits for those.
You know what I should mention
for those interests to,
they can go out of my nonstick media
website and that's g, N, O, s t,
I c media.com and click on the link
up at the top for the farmer cratic
inquisition DVD.
They can watch my whole DVD right there
on the website and it's going to take
him Adderall before you
do this in one year.
Right now it's got all the history of
Santa Claus and Christmas and an amazing
person in there so people can check that
out of the guys he takes them to. Girl.
There's so much information.
So much information. Oh,
Adderall is one of those add drugs. It
makes you retain everything. Oh really?
Yeah. Adderall supposedly as the
best. If you ever want to work,
make these fuckers. Yeah. It's like
cocaine. Yeah. My friend rest his soul,
Robert Schimmel, he, uh, he told
me once that a, someone else,
like in his family or something
was on the Adderall and he
accidentally take, took it, thought it
was something else and a freaked out.
He had no, he did. He completely, because
he had had a heart attack before and uh,
you know, he had, he had
some serious problems, some
health issues. He had cancer.
I'm sorry, we didn't have a heart
attack. He had cancer. Um, so, you know,
he wouldn't be a fucking with something
as crazy as Adderall if he didn't know
what it was. But he said he accidentally
took it. He called this doctor,
doctor said, don't worry about it. You're
going to be fine. You just, you know,
you'll just be under the effects of it for
the next, you know, 10 hours or so, it,
whatever the fuck it is.
And he said he went on a cleaning rampage.
He said he cleaned everything,
organized all of his notes on all
of his material together. He said,
I have never been more focused in my life.
It's for like attention
deficit disorder and stuff.
Yeah.
So that's,
I'm recommending Adderall for Bush sugar
and corn Syrup and red food coloring
and shit.
Well I'm sure it's caused by
a lot of things, but you know,
in nutritional deficiencies are
responsible for a hoard of diseases.
And so many of us just don't
eat, you know, they don't,
we don't take any vitamins.
We don't eat vegetables.
People have been asking me about this
because I talked about on the podcast
about Vitamix blender
fucking thing that I got.
I don't know the name of it because I'm
just sitting right here. I forgot. But um,
it,
what it is is a blender for it takes these
fruits and vegetables and just mashes
them down like almost like they're pre
digested and that's the idea behind it.
That instead of juice,
whereas you taking juice,
you're squeezing all the liquids out
of it and you get a lot of minerals.
And nutrients,
everything like that.
But you don't get as much is
when you chop it up and blend it.
So you chat with them about it.
Kevin James has been on this for
the last year or so and she's lost.
Like I told you like 80 something pounds
when he looks fucking fantastic and he
swears by this shit. So what I've been
eating is just Kale, cucumbers, pairs,
um, and um, uh, raw. Um, what's our stuff?
Ginger and I throw it all together in
that thing and it doesn't taste that good.
But Sally Fallon's book
nourishing traditions. No, no.
What's that about it?
That's a really good one too.
She argues that the whole saturated
animal fats scare is a complete myth and
she's got a lot of
documentation to back it up.
A lot of people think that animal
fat is actually very good for you.
Well, she, she proves that a,
that there was a good scandal with the
oil companies to cover up that animal
fats are oil companies, the oil companies,
because they were selling these new,
newly invented a vegetable oils which
weren't around except for olive oil.
And maybe him. Boy, you didn't
have vegetable oils on the
market before the 1920s.
So she, even if she even shows that
you can, you can parallel the, uh,
the explosion of a heart disease and
cancer in the United States. Exactly.
With the use of vegetable
oils. Exactly. Yep. No kidding.
And she's got this really good Wii
video that you can get it off of Amazon
called the oily and of
America. What, you know,
it's a really slow going video and she's
showing all the documentation on the
screen.
It'll blow your mind.
Steve Maxwell's this master fitness guy,
trainer guy, he's an incredible dude,
but he knows everything about health and
nutrition and exercises and said that
lack
of, uh, animal fat is the reason why
some people can get skin cancer. Well,
body can't like you, like, like
a certain amount of cholesterol,
certain amount of like, right. Well you
need a combination of things in your body.
Basically what causes the heart attacks
and heart disease and all of that shit
is vegetable oils and carbohydrates,
especially process carbos. You know,
if you get rid of those things out
of your diet, heart disease, obesity,
all that shit starts to clear up.
You know,
certainly eat your vegetables and
things, but she says that, you know,
what a lot of people do is they'll go
out and they'll eat a salad and then
they'll pour a salad dressing all over it,
which is these processed vegetable
oils instead of, you know,
all of oil or butter is basically
all you want to use on a salad.
Any of these other new fangled
oils don't eat that shit at all.
So it just,
what happens when you eat it,
your body just has a hard time processing
that your body, that's what all this,
this trans fat scare and what
they also do is, you know,
they're allowed to actually put a half
a gram or anything less than a gram of
trans fat on any packages today is still
able to zero trans fats even though in
it. Yep, we'll do,
do you ever have salad farts salad far
to the most uncomfortable farts ever? No.
Not Vegetable far salad bars cause that
goddamn salad dressing along with all
that.
Yeah.
I usually only use hemp oil or olive
oil and balsamic vinegar on myself.
He put oil on your salad,
credibility signs.
Sometimes you just gotta stop,
put some fucking strawberries
on there in college.
You know it's very nutty. It tastes like
a very similar to olive oil. True Story.
The jerk off with hand boil. No,
no, no. I just figured fuck it man.
Why not try it? Maybe jerk off with
that stuff that actually gets you high.
That shit that a, they sell it. The
little droppers. Do they sell it?
The medical marijuana places
jerk off to that cause it's
Kinda getting your standard.
Dick would be stoned as fuck.
That's funny.
That'd be probably a pretty good
take one states and puts pussy.
Well don't people put like cocaine
on girls' clips and stuff like that.
Talking about you put it on your day off
that girl's pussy. Joey, talk about that.
I forgot all about that. That hotel
in the elevator. I get in and out.
We're doing one's doing
cocaine in the elevator.
There was just a girl just had her little
mirror out. Just fucking, I'm like,
they didn't care. I walked
into the elevator. Hi Vegas.
What happens in Vegas stays in Vegas.
He fuck that shit in the elevator niche.
Look at you. You're ratting
that grow out. Fuck that girl.
There's going to be cops. They're going
to invade that place. Good. You know?
Look for people, fucking
and cocaine. You're going to
ruin the whole Party, Brian.
Good. Why good? Because you didn't stay at
the four seasons and no fucked up. Good,
because you should not pay. If if, if I
wanted to sleep at the hotel impossible.
You should not sell that as a hotel.
You just sell that Brad's eight our lease.
You sound like some delusional bitch.
She could see it. Listen to me.
You sound like a delusional bitch that
goes to a massage parlor where they give
out hand jobs and you didn't know it
was a massage parlor where they give out
hand jobs and you leave and you call
the cops. You're like, what the fuck?
I just want a regular massage.
I paid for rent.
Where's my regular massage?
She massages me for just like five
minutes and she judge Jerky me off.
Do you think every hotel will be like
that? No. It's not every hotel, bro.
It's the fuck hotel everybody else knew.
We know now.
Just like when you go to your hand job,
I'm just saying if you were on
Yelp and you type it in hotel,
that thing has like three and
a half stars. I didn't go, hey,
that looks like a nice hotel.
And they didn't have stars
from people who work there.
You didn't know it was planted.
I didn't know it was a fucking sex hotel.
Now I know now. Well, don't complain now.
Give me my money back when they go
somewhere else. No, no bitch. No.
You had to learn.
You had to pay to learn and now that
you know if you're looking for that,
if you ever looking for a hotel,
do ecstasy and Viagara and just
start fucking a bunch of random.
Now you know the spot. You know the spot
where people are getting their freak on.
Just like if you go to a massage parlor
and they rub your feet and then start
sucking your Dick, you know that's
a different kind of massage parlor.
All right? Don't be
hating Brian. Fuck that
hotel. Don't give out the
name. Even if Yelper if,
if the people at Yelp are listening,
please give me my Yelp elite status back.
Don't give it to you.
He's my friend and I'd say ignore
his requests. Fuck you, dude.
It's ridiculous, Hayden. Right? Don't
you think he's say, that's total party.
I would love to have seen [inaudible]
Williams for Todd McCord. Mccord.
You will ever see Joe turn around
and go to another hotel. Yeah,
because you can do, man, you just
got to be willing to bite the bullet.
Chomp down.
Yeah.
Fuck that hotel in has in
the ass. How rude, dude.
That's all I have to say to you. How
rude. She didn't call it a hotel.
That's all I'm saying.
Another guy we hung out with this weekend
was a George sucralose, sucralose,
sucralose, Giorgio sucralose, the
guy from ancient aliens. Right.
What a fascinating cat and do is awesome.
He is great.
We had a great fucking time, man. He
was way cooler than I could've imagined.
Both him and Anthony
Bordain way cooler than,
I couldn't imagine Giorgio
came back stage with us.
I don't want to say he smoked some weed.
We had a great fucking time.
We hung out with me and that dude like
right away clicked instantly.
You know,
he makes some fantastical
claims on that show,
but you know when you talk to him in
real life, he ain't married to anything.
He's not married to any thought.
You know, we discussed aliens,
we discussed possibilities.
He's like,
it's just a possibility and there's
another possible and there's nothing and
he's not married to any of them and
he's super cool and a really nice guy.
He comes off, I liked him on
the show. I liked that wacky.
I would be like this wacky motherfucker.
He's like saying all kinds of crazy shit.
But sometimes he would annoy me.
I'm going to be honest,
like you said, like,
like maybe Atlantis was a
spaceship and took off. You know,
maybe my Dick is a helicopter
and I'll fly to Mars. Like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Maybe Santa Claus as a, but I don't
have any evidence for it. Yeah, you
just completely dismiss it. It's
nonsense, but it's a show, right?
That's what he's doing. He's doing a TV
show and when you're doing a TV show,
look,
you know,
I could tell you right off the bat there's
some shit that you say that kind of
move the show along,
you know,
and there's some shit that you say may
maybe what if maybe you want to hear
something crazy.
I'll give you some crazy shit.
You want a sound bite and I'll give you
a sound bite and maybe, and you know,
you might not even believe that. Maybe
what you say it anyway, but in real life,
talking to him in real life,
he's cool as fuck great hair to
his fucking hair's all crazy.
It's like some crazy peacock fan going
on. He, she fucking owns it, dude.
He owns it. He loves it. He has
crazy beads on and shit. Yeah, I did.
Very nice jeans.
I dig him.
He's going to be on show
July 27 this weekend.
It's going to be me and mad flavor.
Aka Joe Diaz at the Irvine Improv.
That is a Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
You dirty dirty Orange
County bridges and uh,
this is going to be a, it's almost sold
out on Friday and Saturday already.
And then Sunday is um,
the 10th is the last day we're doing it.
So it should be a lot of fun. You know,
that's an awesome club. Irvine is a place,
it's a great place to do stand up.
I love that level.
That whole area down there before yeah.
Is Nice.
It's like a nice little oasis of
cool shit to do. Like a Ferris wheel.
Is that one of the Ferris wheel?
I think it has a Ferris wheel.
There's the one with the
first is in Irvine. Yeah.
There was even a place out
back to smoke out. Yeah.
We'll start with you got to have that
if you're going to have a goddamn comedy
show.
Yeah.
I got a little nervous that Anthony
Bourdain was in the audience and I was
worried if I was too high. I was like,
how many hits I have? I had three heads.
Shit, I'm skiing right now. Cause
when you have three heads you got it.
For as long as I know that I've gone over
my material and I know that I've been
performing a lot and I know
that I'm in the groove,
I can just go out there and ski.
And by skiing means you never watched
those videos where a dude gets dropped on
top of a mountain on the helicopter and
then do a lot of cocaine and then he's
going down that mountain and it's some
uncharted territory and you know this guy
fucking hits a rock the wrong way.
He's done right.
This guy's coming back behind. Yeah,
the avalanche behind them and you know,
there's no way he can stop. He cannot
control this. He's going way too fast.
That's how you feel when
you get three hits in.
They kind of know what
the fuck you're doing.
When you go on stage that hot you gotta
be prepared. But fortunately I was,
fortunately I was completely
comfortable in, in the groove.
These comedy shows have gotten 80%
better in the last year and a half.
And it's because of the podcast.
It's 100% because of the podcast.
I asked people on stage,
how many guys listen to the podcast?
The place went fucking crazy.
It was all of them.
It was all 1500 people that were
there that it's, it's nuts man.
They're all polite and friendly.
It's like he used to be like,
you have to battle just
to get ground on stage.
And now when Joey and Ari
and Doug Benson one onstage,
all three of them got
huge rounds of applause.
Like everybody was psyched to see Ari
there was psyched to see Joey there was
psyched to see Doug. It's a just an
amazing thing now. It's so different.
Even in huge to that place is so huge.
That's where the lion king is like
usually this huge fucking show is usually
there and now it's good. I know we
packed it just talking. It's ridiculous.
Comedy is a strange thing, but the, it's
still my favorite thing to watch, man.
You know,
I thought about staying an extra day.
I was going to stay until Sunday cause
bill burr and Jim Norton and Jim Breuer
and Dave Attell are all doing a show
together at the palm and up for a minute.
I was thinking, why don't I, you know,
fly out Mrs Rogan for the day and
we'll go to see a comedy show.
Like maybe she would be into that. And
I'm like, can we get the fuck home?
You know,
I changed my mind but I do love stand
up so much that I almost stayed an extra
day to watch this show because I went
out to dinner Saturday night with Jim
Norton and Bill Burr and uh,
my friend Justin from the actual report
and Russell Peters were there too.
And so we're all sitting around and
Kenny, you know, clubs would have county.
We're all sitting around
shooting the shit.
And they were telling me
about Jim brewers new bit.
Jim Breuer apparently has some clothes
or that is just insane about him.
His Dad taking a ship and they were
all talking about like how this,
this thing builds up like
his dad shit in the car.
His Dad's like an older guy and apparently
it's the funniest fucking better one
bed time. And they were, and
I was like [inaudible] know.
Right, right. Yeah. Okay.
Vegan called that.
I know he's doing well. He did. He did.
He did well in front of large audiences.
Ice House Thursday,
Brian went on in front of a,
I mean one of the first times ever got
him to do comedy. All right, this is,
this has got, you know, this took Matt
balls. This was way before the podcast.
The audience was all meat heads.
It was a UFC audience in Atlanta
and it was a midnight show.
So it was a midnight fucking show.
And Brian goes on in the middle
of the fucking show and kills you.
You and you pulled yourself out of the
fire because you started bombing and then
you pulled yourself out of the fire and
then at the end you ended like really
strong. And that was the first time he
did comedy and like years and years.
Six years. Really? Yeah.
But then I've thrown them up a bunch of
times and I'm throwing them up in Austin,
Texas in front of sold out crowds.
And you know it's interesting like your,
your introduction to comedy is 1000%
different than the average person's
introductions cheat codes.
It's traded on two ways.
One because everybody knows who
you are before you can go on stage.
Cause then you'll get from the podcast
now and they know you from all of the
videos that you've made. You know, if you
ever watched the Carlos men see a video,
that was Brian's work and all,
there's all these videos called death
squad videos are all Brian's work.
And so they already know who you are
and you're an open mic or basically,
you know,
you're just starting out and yet they
still know who you are and they're all
clapping and cheering to watch
you practice out your new jokes.
Yeah, it kind of sucks
cause I, there's more,
a little bit more pressure because now
people know who I am and now I'm getting
thrown up in front of sold out show
is I actually have to act somewhat.
Like I fit in,
you know,
you just do it.
Just be relaxed.
You a smoked some weed before you go on
to that idea. I found Brian has to, uh,
you, you could go and, and I'm not dissing
you in any way. I'm just being honest.
You could go and work with a coach
who would help you learn how to speak.
I figured it out. It's, it's got 100%
marijuana. It, I, it does not work for me.
When I get stoned, my brain goes, no,
I can still, my brain goes overdrive.
I'm thinking a thousand things at once.
Like I'm almost like
trying to figure out,
you know,
you don't need to learn how to
manage it with your mouth. Yeah.
But when I'm on stage, my, like
my memories everywhere, you know,
you just got to do it more.
Go Do it 20 or 30 times and get
over that and then it'll kick.
Okay. I found, but I just found
that, you know, I'd rather not,
I'd rather just go out
with like a drink in me
and I'm good. No, try to
get me to go on stage.
What about six years ago and I
chickened out. He checked it out.
I tried to get everybody to do it. Smart.
I think someone's smart. I'm like, look,
if you're smart, you can figure it out.
Comedy, if you're smart, you're nice,
and you make your friends laugh, you could
figure it out. Colony, it ain't easy,
but God damn,
if you could do it,
it's the greatest job in
the history of the world. I,
I'm constantly trying to recruit
people to try stand up comedy.
I ran into some fucking
17 year old kid in Vegas.
I've talked to him for 20 minutes because
him and his friend were thinking about
doing standup comedy and they're asking
me for advice and I said, all right,
I'm not doing anything. I'll, I'll
tell you everything I know. You know,
this is what you gotta do.
You gotta write like fucking crazy.
You've got to go up every time you can
and you got to listen to your own shit.
Go back and listen to recordings.
Be Honest. If a bid is bombing,
try it differently.
And if it,
you eventually you're gonna have to
give up on that bitch and move on.
Constantly keep writing.
Like we went on this long thing,
I go put yourself in positions where,
you know, some weird shit might go down.
That's a good way to write material.
Like you've got to think that way.
You gotta be a professional party
animal, you know, for real, like the,
the greatest comics ever.
The Richard Pryor's and Sam Kinison,
they were out there getting shit done.
All right.
It wasn't just going on stage and talk
and they were living a crazy life too.
That's part of the program to, I
don't, it doesn't mean abusive.
It doesn't mean what they did, but
it means, you know, try shit out.
So fucking on the 15 at 200 miles an
hour and getting a head on. Yeah. I mean,
that's why I needed to,
Colorado was one of the reasons
besides wanting to get away,
I knew that I was gonna get
some material out of that.
Like you've got to do things like that.
So I, I, I'm a fucking huge supporter,
standup comedy. I tried to get everybody
to do it. I tried to get taped to do it.
I got you to do it while you're
done it before. But I got, you know,
I've gotten a couple of people to do
what I've got to Eddie Bravo to do it.
It's just nobody sticks with it.
That was the big thing is,
is that it's definitely,
I think something you have to start
when you're younger and you have to make
that year career and I think all these
people that you had try it. Yeah.
They had their own thing going and they
were doing it as for fun on the side.
Kind of like what I do.
But they're not,
they don't want that as a job because
it cause that's really risky to do it.
Right.
Well, you're 36 hours to do it.
We were all young, you know. Fuck.
Wow.
Have you ever driven a home from Vegas
and see night that abandoned water slide.
Amusement side of the,
yeah.
Oh, what the hell was the,
uh, it's creepy. Like Dolores,
that's what it was. Yeah.
We were going to break into it and just
like walk around with some cameras and
stuff on the way home. But we are, the
traffic was so bad so we decided not to.
So if there's this Wikipedia page all
about it and it's so amazing the history
of that amusement park,
like in the fifties and sixties this
businessman bought it and he just put this
water slide amusement park in the middle
of the Mojave desert I think it is or
something like that in the middle of the
desert and there's this huge waterpark
knows fifties themes.
It was like very like fifties
music and sixties music and stuff
like that. And it just, you know,
it was millions of dollars in the,
I remember in like the late seventies
and eighties all the time on TV you would
see like Dolores commercials and
stuff, but the, you know, you know,
they would say it's time I 15 but they
didn't tell you is three fucking hours
from here.
So
[inaudible] bought it and renamed it
things every 10 years it would close and
then be closed for like five years.
And somebody else would read by and try
for a year and then we'd go bankrupt and
now somebody else is just a,
just bought it again is trying it again.
And they have like this whole youtube
page and website all about them,
like restoring it and stuff like that.
It is the dumbest idea ever.
Like people are fucking retarded.
Going to go through the middle
of a desert to go to, you know,
see what the, I guess for them, like
they're planning on that business.
When you have the, the occasional car
accident, it shuts down the whole fuck,
right.
Let's go to the water bar,
stock car accidents and they're all in
the lay down some fucking nails trips.
Oh Man. Let me now share on Memorial
Day weekend out in Vegas. And it's like,
it was like 1214 hours getting
across that four hours. Anyway,
man, it sucked, man. 14
hours. Really? It was,
it was five,
10 miles an hour most of the way.
Imagine if you had a
clutch. Oh God. Oh God.
That took me six hours yesterday
driving a standard kind of traffic.
We'll drive you fucking
insane. Yeah. Six hours.
Don't fucking drive. Ever. Never
expanded that she went back.
You got caught going back. I'm going
back. I didn't think about going there.
You went easy, right? Easy. Three hours
and 15 minutes and fucking amazing.
Super fast.
Way Back.
We stayed an extra day so I could
do a set at the nightly show and,
and then um, I didn't think about it.
I'm like, wait, everyone has Monday off.
So they're probably going to have probably
have to work Tuesday so everybody's
going to be traveling back Monday.
So I picked the worst data
ever drive back from Vegas.
It was only [inaudible] you go
to a flight. Yeah, absolutely.
And that's leaving 9:00 AM to, I
mean I left fucking early. Wow.
9:00 AM six hours. Yeah. You
gotta go like four in the morning.
You gotta just stay up there. Just got
to take those five hour energy drinks.
Jenna Hayes did that to a like that one.
I'm just slightly less than
what you get with it. Stroke,
just less than a strokes dose and then
just ride that bitch just right when you
started twitching.
That's what all night foot to the
fucking floor looking out for coyotes,
both human and otherwise. Right. That's
a creepy fucking stretch of road man.
Those,
that's boulevard
you. They were supposed to put a bullet
train out there like 10 years ago.
I think it never did.
And I think they're still doing it from,
isn't it from Santa Monica to
Vegas or something like that.
You have to come up long
dollars to make that happen.
Okay. Do you know, and it's
such a long highway, you know
it's been, it's been, what,
two lanes since the fricking sixties yeah.
It's ridiculous that the road is
ridiculous this, but you know what,
there was no one's going to
do anything different because the airline
industry doesn't want anybody driving.
You know, the airline industry
wants everybody, you know,
flying as much as possible.
And then what,
who's going to spend the money to Wa
is Vegas going to spend the money that
you've talking about a lot
of fucking money problems.
Nobody else is going to want
to like why would we do that?
How about you figure it out in
your own fuck face and sure.
California has casinos as well. Yeah.
It's probably put a dampener on the whole,
but they don't really have
casinos. I mean, they do and
they don't, you know, it's,
they're not full casinos.
You can't do everything at the casinos.
You can't play slots and blackjack
and poker. You know what I mean?
It's like you have like
little restrictions like this
one. You can only do this.
There's these, you don't let to play
cards. Casino. Yeah. You might know this.
I had a lot of people have been
telling me this lately that the medical
marijuana in Vegas, you can use your
California license and they accept it.
The California license in Vegas do that
in a couple different states. Really?
Yeah. They told me they
do that in Denver as well.
No, no. That's the first I heard.
Yeah. Todd Todd or Chris Conrad would
be open, I guess. Yeah,
you would have to a,
it would be different things state
by state, you know, but they, oh,
they took it when we were in a Vancouver.
Yeah.
When Vancouver they accepted
our California recommendations.
You need one in Vancouver because last
time I was up there there was blunt
brothers and stuff.
You could just,
you'll be seeing smoke British Columbia,
not Vancouver, Washington. No. Yeah,
you did. There was um,
there was a pharmacies,
now they have dispensaries
in Vancouver. BC. Rice. Yeah.
They're setting it up just like
California. But California has at the,
we're at the front. Oh
yeah. The front of mine.
There's nowhere will like this
anywhere on the planet. I don't know.
Well, you know, and uh, right now
Amsterdam was shutting everything down.
So guess where all that business
is going to start coming? It's,
see there's going to be here.
It's going to be Vancouver.
You see the fuck is Amsterdam thinking
that was the dumbest shit ever.
You guys are known for
weed and you're going
and that's,
and it's been legal for what,
35 years or something and now they're
going to shut it down to only residents.
What the hell, you know?
Yeah. What does that,
what it is too many people
tripping and fucking, I mean,
you'll get like 10 but see how many people
do dumb shit on alcohol every night.
Alcohol is by far the worst drug
out there in every study ever done.
But when you have,
you know Frank's house and there's people
showrooming like Dunkin donuts every
Sunday,
every couple of people that dove off a
bridge and committed suicide on mushrooms
and Amsterdam.
And it's like,
you know how many fricking people do that
shit at night on alcohol and, and, and,
you know, Holland alone. Well,
so scared. It's like, oh my God,
they would have done it anyway.
It's way easier to a band things
than it is to make things legal.
And we make it very easy to
write things off and decide that,
you know, like there's people, right?
Behavior, oh my God.
People without any studies
whatsoever. They're trying to outlaw
Salvia, you know, and they're,
they're pulling it off in,
in various states and making it illegal.
And there's no research behind
any of this. They're just pulling.
Oh yeah. And all this stuff is scare
tactics. You know, it's like this kid did,
you know, a couple of years ago,
there was this big scare back east.
This kid had done salvia
several months before,
wrote in his diary that he could see how
half the shit in his life was complete
bullshit. He was starting to see
through the big fucking lie out there.
And then they said, you know,
months later they tried to say, oh,
well he committed suicide
because of Salvia,
even though he was not on Salvia and
he had done it months before, you know,
it's, it's that he, you know,
he certainly started seeing how a lot
of what the media and government and
things like that tell you is bullshit
until they come up with a suicide.
It's like saying, you know, Lsd, you know,
somebody waking up from LSD like a
Timothy leary and then years later they
commit suicide. Oh, it's because
it was because of the LSD. Okay.
But you can clearly make some sort of
a connection between some of those kids
that got experimented on in Harvard,
like Ted Kaczynski and
his behavior afterwards.
We'll sure there is a connection
between really. Yeah. You know,
I would love to know what trips,
what they did to him.
I would really like to know what they
did to Ted Kaczynski. The unibomber.
Ted Kaczynski was a part of the
Harvard LSD studies and he was,
he was a professor of math up at Berkeley.
This was no dumb shit.
This was a top scholar. Yeah. He
just completely lost his marbles.
Presumably during these LSD experiments.
Maybe they expose something.
Maybe they, uh, they broke. So what's
that documentary called about him?
That's a good question. I
don't remember. Oh, shoot. Is
that, I've seen it. Yeah. Yeah.
I forget. Just look up, look up
a unibomber documentary. I'm,
I'm sure you'll find it,
but it's a, yeah, it's,
it's about something with the computer
industry as well, I think. Yes,
yes. Well, you know, he, uh,
it's really fascinating what
he did when, when is it? No,
that's a new one. When your brother
was the Unabomber, the net than that.
Exactly. That's it. Um, he, uh,
he saved up all his money after
these studies and worked, uh,
as a professor of mathematics at Berkeley.
And when he was working there,
he was just studying and saving up his
money and trying to figure out what the
fuck he was going to do when he moved
to the woods and how he was going to
tactics.
Yeah.
You know,
I would love to know who was in
charge of the study that he was in.
Was it Dick Alpert?
Was it Tim leary?
What he did was absolutely horrible.
You know, and what he did for sure,
that guy should go to jail for it for
sure. He was absolutely insane for sure.
He was homicidal.
But the thought behind what he was
saying was that technology is eventually
going to kill us.
Right. Well, yeah, we need to stop. Well,
basically what he was arguing was that
they're using the technology to enslave
everybody and to dumb us down
and to control everything.
And he was trying to stop it because
he started being the math professor at
Berkeley started seeing how the whole
system worked and he wanted to shut it
down. Right. I mean, well, the
way he did it was nice and saying,
you know what kills a bunch. Yeah, he, Oh
fuck people's lives up. You know, he's,
he went about it. You know, he
didn't use critical thinking.
Properly run is an
analysis of his solution,
but there's something to what he sang.
The idea that technology eventually is
going to overtake us. It's absolutely,
I mean it's discussed in depth
by thousands of scientists
and futurists and the
rate Kurt's and my grandfather,
your grandfather talks about that
shit and hates technology so that it's
overtaking us. Just to say
that all the time. Well,
I think anybody at our grandfather's,
an older guy grew up in a time where
there was no phones and no nothing.
We put out a documentary
last November called, uh,
what you've been missing in
episode one of the noble lie,
which goes into this whole use
of technology to dumb us down.
So anybody wants to check that out. Look
it up. I think it's a silly argument.
I don't think,
I don't think it dumbs us down.
I think there are dumber people than ever.
It's because life has
become easy for them.
It's easy to become dumb or checkout
and checkout the how they're,
they're doing it.
They're using the BF Skinner's ideas
from the Skinner box and how they
controlled animals and things like that.
Uh,
there's a lot of Edward Bernays was
talking about, what are you talking about?
Well,
Skinner,
the Skinner box is a box that they would
put a pigeons and rats and things like
that and get them to do certain things
for food or whatever on a stimuli.
And they've learned to apply that stuff
directly to computer games and to,
uh, you know, purchasing and the grocery
stores and things like things like that.
But what checkouts checkout
checkout, it's, you know,
it's an hour and a half long documentary.
Just, you know, what you've been missing.
Episode one,
check it out sometimes what you've been
missing episode one and it did. Okay.
And they can,
they can go to the gnostic media website
and click on the videos thing there and
it'll be right there. Okay. Okay.
And the, what is the conclusion?
Well that there are certain people using
marketing and advertising and computer
technology, uh, to specifically to
mind control people. And it's very,
very simple to do. Is it mind control?
It's mine. It's mine controlled at,
at face value when, once you see how
it works, it's just, it's real blade.
Do you accept the argument though that
marketing is mind control and they're
getting people obsessed? Socio Jack?
See the thing how mind control works is,
you know,
I mentioned this trivium thing earlier
by people not having the trivium.
That's what enables marketing and public
relations, the polyp political system,
the last system that we have today,
that's what enables it to work.
That stuff wouldn't be able to function.
That's why it doesn't work on
any intelligent person. And He,
no intelligent person watches any nonsense
propaganda on television and buys it
immediately because you've accumulated
a certain amount, like you know,
say if you go out and you study logical
fallacies for 20 minutes and then you go
study commercials,
you'll see how every commercial
is filled with logical fallacies.
So once you can identify
those logical fallacies,
you begin to see how they're using
these lies against you everywhere.
And then you just block them out. What's
the end game though? And like, well,
the end game is just to learn your own,
your own gain,
your own autonomy,
your own adulthood.
Really it's to see through the
crap and gain yourself back.
It is important though,
to enjoy life, right?
It is important to do this and to figure
out how to enjoy life. Don't you think?
Oh, I definitely see here, let
me, let me put it to you this way.
And in ancient Roman times,
they considered those who had studied
the seven liberal arts is free and those
who didn't were slaves.
The slaves were not allowed to
study the seven liberal arts,
this trivium or quadrivium thing.
As soon as you got free of slavery,
that was the first thing you
did was undertake a study
of the seven liberal arts,
right?
So let's say nobody in our society in
the masses even has that education now.
So we would be considered in
Roman times the slave class. Okay?
So when you see the word
freedom, literally, uh,
which is what the word liberal is,
is from the Latin word book.
Liebherr and so Liebherr and uh,
library liberty, these are
really on me Bro, isn't this,
this is what we'll hold on that horizon.
This is where it calls out.
This is where freedom comes from.
So when people learn this stuff,
this is how they got free.
So you know,
it's the difference of knowing
that you're a slave free from,
totally agree with you on this.
We're basically,
this is a very complicated way of saying
that our education system sucks and it
could possibly be set
up that way on purpose.
Don't dumb your audience down too
much, Bro. It's not dumbing them down.
Kind of fill in the voids here. I'm
trying to bring this show back to life.
The idea is that good. And at one
point in time, uh, people were,
were taught this stuff on a regular
basis and now our education system is no
longer a pizza, been completely
removed from people's education.
Does that really is on purpose?
Do you think that's it? Oh yeah,
there's evidence that it was done
on purpose. We don't, and in fact,
I just saw an article by this woman
Kelly from Canada free press yesterday
talking about, uh, the American, uh,
freedom or the American rebellion,
uh,
from England was originally
centered around the trivium
and classical education.
Okay. So when people are in a
school today, you know, when,
when they come up with some sort of a,
a little lesson plan for the year,
is there someone who's actually saying,
hey, we don't want these people smarter.
Let's like dumb shit down and
you can see if you happening.
Whereas if people want evidence of that,
they can study Charlotte is or beats book.
Do you believe this Brian now and as well,
I would suggest people study two people,
primarily John Taylor Gatto and he's
written a very good book. The America,
the underground history of underground
history of American education for people
that read and also Charlotte is or
beats book the dumbing down of America,
which she also has a lot of primary
documents in her book on the Reese
Commission and how they dictate stuff.
Check it out before you dismiss it.
Let's say those two names. Now they're
under more time. You're freaking people.
The fuck out people on Twitter right now
is saying this is the most name drops
anyone has ever had in the podcast.
Please fucking write this shit somewhere.
I'm freaking out because John
Taylor, Gatto and Charlotte is, or B,
these are the last people's books we're
going to tell people to read because
otherwise we're going to look like
God damn. University studies go.
We'll just go onto my website. I've got
a video up on Gatto right on my website.
They can look at it. They're okay.
They'll do that. Now you, you,
how long have you been into this?
This,
this studying of psychedelic
chemicals and you know, the between,
you know, these, uh, these
things and religions and you,
you've been in this for a long ass time,
but how did you ever get into it to
the point where this is how you make a
living?
Well, let's see. I've been in
it at least 20, 22 years or so,
but, uh, originally I got in at working
with Jack Herer on the California health
initiative and he was the one who
originally turned me on to a John Allegro,
his book, the sacred mushroom in
the cross. And, uh, I, you know,
how did you feel like when
you first discovered this
stuff? But I thought, Jack,
the bat shit crazy when he first
told me about it. The same when you,
when you met us and you thought
we were completely crazy.
I didn't think he was crazy.
I thought, first of all,
I'd been exposed to a bunch of things
that I never would have thought it existed
before by that time. So I was already
open to the possibility, like,
who the fuck knows?
I'm pretty ignorant as to the way the
universe really operates. You know,
just started reading about quantum
physics and you know what I mean?
Like you start reading about things in
super position where a particle is moving
and not moving and in one place
and another at the same time.
And like what the fuck is real and
what's not and what does the Observer,
so when then some guy tells you that
he thinks that mushrooms, you know,
probably shaped religion.
That's not even crazy.
Where'd you meet Jack and I? A grateful
dead concert or at school actually,
my sister turned me onto his book when
I was probably 18 and then I had met him
at a hemp rally and December,
2002 I went to his house and we instantly
hit it off and we were friends for 18
years and I was one of the people
that help bury him in April last year.
Because you, you know, on
your show for sure, you preach
to the converted, you know,
and you have a, a really, uh,
a big following of people who like me
are kind of pretty well versed in this
subject matter and, and understand a lot
about, you know, psychedelic drugs and,
and you know,
the,
the relationship they've had to humanity
for thousands and thousands of years.
But what about the average person once
you run into like some regular square
dude and he,
so what do you, first of all, he's
got to get by your name. Jaan yeah,
it looks like Jan to me cause it's
way he spells it Scandinavian,
right?
Yeah,
he's only English pronounces Jay is just
so it's more like you're yawning like,
oh, well, you know, you have
Johann or, or something like that.
Viking blood in your past.
I'm primarily a Danish,
Welsh and Scottish and he viking
in there. Any of those? Possibly.
Who knows who's a viking? What
was it? What was it? Norway.
Yeah, the Norris. Norris.
The North men. Right.
Okay. So no viking. Eric.
Hmm.
But now,
but what is squares do when you,
you meet some regular dude like in your
neck of the woods and your small town
that you live in and he's like, so what
are your right about there? Yeah. Oh well
I don't, you know, it's interesting.
I usually don't even talk about
it in my neck of the woods.
I'm usually so busy with work
and doing my show and you know,
it takes me two hours to answer all the
emails and I hear from people all the
time to see my work online and Holy Shit,
I just saw your work and it
completely blew me away. But you know,
I very rarely have people that
come to me and just say, oh, that's
completely bat shit crazy.
How often do you communicate about what
you do to someone who is completely
uninitiated? It's, what
I'm trying to say is,
I have had some
conversations before and uh,
one of them I had on a plane with a doctor
and he was a very intelligent guy and
uh, we, we sat down and you know,
he was just being real
friendly and started off with
like fear factor questions
and then somebody
start off, you know, with,
with ancient primary sources and
things like that because you know,
a doctor's gonna want to cut
straight to the facts. No bullshit.
So just give him the primary text
says, listen, listen iconography,
listen dude, it's a social
situation. You're having a
drink with a guy on a plane,
you know, breaking things down for them.
You just talking, shooting the shit.
And we broached the subject of first
marijuana and then he was asking you about
that book, Dmt, the spirit molecule
that was sitting on my table.
You just mentioned another boat.
So you have this guy where
you're talking to him.
So he's an intelligent guy that's like
50 years old that has no experience
whatsoever in anything psychedelic.
And when I started describing the
experience and I started talking about it,
then he started getting interested and
then he started talking to me about it.
And then he started writing things down
and he started like taking little notes
on it and things that he wanted to
investigate. And he asked me, you know,
like where it could get the book,
you know, it was it on a website.
Can I get it on Amazon?
You know,
somebody for something that
might be easier for a guy
like that would be like Dr
Roland Griffiths work.
Oh, he's fucking name
dropping again. This con
Roland Griffiths.
Look sorry.
Is his study silicide been a
religious experience and that was,
that was all over the news a couple of
years ago. The most recent one. Yeah.
It's very recent stuff.
Psilocybin and religious experience.
And what's this dude's name again?
Roland Griffiths. You know, it's, I mean,
how many fucking more books can come out
about it before they start teaching it
in mainstream mainstream?
Well, you know what's interesting
is, is, uh, in December,
Loma Linda University Medical Center,
which is a seventh Adventist, uh,
medical school. And it's considered
one of the best in the world.
They had me come in and like a Mormon
seven days. No, it's not Mormons,
but seventh day Adventists.
They're seventh day Adventists while
there is a Christian group. But uh,
anyway, they worship on Saturday
and Sunday instead of Saturday.
The worship on the sabbath
basically. So, uh, this,
this school had me come into their
pharmacy department and give a two hour
lecture on the history of the medical
and spiritual applications of psychedelic
drugs.
Whoa.
What was that like?
Did you get a lot of hippie
chicks to have the show Montana?
I want to get a piece of that author.
We just have,
I have so many thoughts that
was so similar to yours.
Real freaky. You must get
through. Fortunately the,
the class was those who were allowed to
participate where the top of the class,
so they couldn't, uh, you know,
there were, there were no,
anybody who thought that they thought
was going to deviate from the norm of
society were even allowed
to attend the lecture. Sure.
Wow. Huh. Do you get psychedelic groupies?
Do you get girls who are like
interested because they're like really?
And decided that Alex,
there's their colors. Yeah.
There's been some your arms.
He has a beautiful Arra got the same sign
as me. I see you in your documentary.
How this connection,
the farmer credit inquisition.
I was never in the documentary,
but they can see me in the one that
you and I were in American drug war.
Yeah. That was a long ass time ago. Right.
Did they wind up using your,
your footage in that?
Yeah, they use like 15 seconds or 30
seconds or something of it. It's um,
and then, uh, Kevin Booth, he was going
to use a lot more of that later on,
but I guess never went back to it.
It's w what I was saying is what I was
trying to address by asking you what it's
like when you talked to her regular
people that don't have any experience in
this. It's a, it's a very weird subject
to broach all of it. The, the, the,
the use of psychedelic drugs as
anything more than a party favor.
But you know what's interesting
is his last April up in San Jose,
there's a group called maps,
the Multidisciplinary Association
for Psychedelic Studies.
They hold a huge conference. It was
the first one in like 35 or 40 years,
but there was eight or 900 doctors and
professors there at this conference.
And the whole thing was about the
latest research and psychedelics.
And it's a regular basis, right?
This is, uh, there, there, well they,
they are planning,
there are different ones,
but this was the first and the largest
is a national one instead of regionals I
would have is, well this one was,
it was the largest where they,
it was like spread out over three days,
uh, almost a hundred presenters. You know,
literally people come flying
in from all over the world,
medical professionals
from all over the world,
experts in psychedelics presenting
on just everything. So, I mean,
you know, the, the, the,
the psychedelic craze and fear of the
60s is pretty much a over and it's
becoming a lot more in tune
with the academic side and
with real knowledge about
psychedelics instead of just the
fear that was put out by the,
the mass media for the last 40 years.
So you really think there's a shift,
you really think that things are
actually changing? Oh, yeah. Well,
because it was a recent,
just in the last six or eight months,
I think maybe it was, uh, October
last year, uh, uh, ecstasy,
Mtma was approved for treating PTSD
and military professionals and a,
there's pilot studies pilot
treatment studies happening
in, uh, in Colorado. Right.
And how often is that happening now or?
Well,
it's actually giving Mtma to people
that Israel is using it. Uh, there's a,
a couple of other different places that
are already using it for the treatment
of Ptsd. Uh, right. But is that
actually happening in America? Yes,
it's happening in Colorado right now. It's
already been approved for use. And, uh,
the one thing that's approved for use in
almost every other country in the world
is he boga from the Ibogaine
in the treatment of alcoholism
and heroin and opium
addiction.
And that's got like a 92% success rate.
But unfortunately the United States is
one of the only countries in the world
where we're drug addiction
treatment is illegal with, uh,
with Ibogaine.
And a Iowasca is also been shown to
be very effective in the treatment of,
of alcoholism and opiate addiction.
Yeah.
Yeah. We're held captive what we're held
captive by corrupt politicians. Oh, sure,
sure. Yeah. You know, from
special interest groups and,
and that's what's wrong with it.
Right?
Yeah. I don't want to drop any names
that people can, if people are,
if there's any addicts out there
that want more information,
contact me through my wedding.
You can find Ibogaine research places
in Mexico where they have, I'm sure
Canada or pretty much anywhere in Europe.
I didn't know they haven't been Canada,
but I know a buddy who was gone to
Mexico several times to do it and he said
that it's changed his entire life,
changed the way it looks at everything,
and they made him see himself for who he
really is and abandoned all those false
patterns of behavior that he had gotten
stuck with and all the false connections
that he had made in his mind that
we're constantly tripping them up.
Yeah.
Ibogaine actually blocks the,
the opiates ability to trigger
those receptors in your body.
So you come down from this 12 or 24 hour
trip and you are literally not addicted
anymore.
It cuts that addiction off and now
and at the same time it's like a,
you know the, in Aa when you
have to have the life review it,
it forces that life
review in that long trip.
So it not only do you get the life review,
but at the end of the trip it blocks
you from being addicted anymore.
It's like it's designed to cure
you of any wrong. A dense, yeah.
And it's an extremely
powerful psychedelic.
It's been used by the weedy and Africa
for thousands of years and yet it's
illegal and it's illegal.
The US passed in the
1970 classification that,
that whole ruling that made all
those different psychedelic drugs,
was it just lumped into there as I
might say, I'm sure it probably was.
What's amazing is the ones that didn't
get lumped in there and they didn't know
about like five methoxy DMT,
the most
full psychedelic on earth.
And there is a church operating in the
United States called Toad Tuya de, uh,
that operates using a five
methoxy and dimethyl trip
domains. And this may or may not
have happened. It might be fiction,
but a long time ago,
maybe me and yon did some of that shit.
Maybe, uh, maybe we learned
a lot and we paid him.
He bought it online.
Maybe we bought it online easy.
Don't do DMT with Eddie Bravo.
Yeah, Eddie is, he's
grown as a man since then,
although now he's wearing
me with his love for bunnies
can ever happen to it. Channeling.
He's ready to have a child.
And so now he's like really into bunnies.
And the loving, loving, small things.
In fact that Eddie Bravo can
make me almost cry now is
amazing about a bunny. No,
like just when we had
him on that last podcast,
they was just stick the most on his
sign and everything. I was like damn,
this is a softer side of Sears.
Yeah.
And then he shut down on
us in the conversation.
It was like just fucking ended it
hit a wall and just dropped off.
And then Eddie Saturday with a sad face
and Brian was half asleep. So I'm like,
Hey,
is anybody out there like that fucking
show with the guys on the radio trying to
talk to past sheet.
Remember?
Oh it was in the movie contact.
Remember she was trying to call
her saddest moment of all time.
The little girl was trying to call
her dad. Yeah, she almost got to him.
She couldn't get the medicine to them.
That was pretty solid.
So what am I was trying to get at is do,
do you ever have any interaction with
regular people who just think you're
fucking crazy for studying this
stuff? You turn off, do you turn off?
Occasionally you'll have the person who's
never looked at any of the research or
evidence call up when I'll do a radio
interview view or something all freaked
out about it.
But you know,
they're telling people to do drugs and I
think what you're doing, it's raw. Yeah,
you've got, you know, I
mean, you should be manage.
Me and Johnny Rotten gave you DMT and
look what happened after that, you know?
Yeah, yeah. Johnny rotten was on
the podcast once we talked about it,
about psychedelic trembling
changes the whole world.
Because if you go through that and
you, uh, your world doesn't change,
well then man, you must have known
something already. You must have already,
I mean, it must be the
smartest person in the world.
How could you not improve radically
multistate consciousness theory.
Mckenna had the best
description of it and his,
his description was that he looked at
your culture as an operating system and he
said that there is only one way to
a band in this operating system.
You have to take something,
a program that, that,
that sort of reprograms your operating
system and you could do it and he hadn't,
you know, name out all these different
psychedelic compounds and he said,
or you could do it in DMT form,
which is like a compressed,
you know, 15 minute for him. You know,
it's like taking Shannon's shut file,
you know, and, and uh, unzipping
and into your hard drive, just boom,
you got to change two terabytes
of new information that flying in.
It was not something
that everybody should do.
I think some people have a
hard time with regular life.
I think some people have a hard time
with just a fucking getting through life
and it could be a whole host
of things wrong with them.
That's largely because of
societal conditioning in an,
in the first place. So, so gets
caught in this catch 22 loop.
It could be medical,
it could be a lot of other things.
There's some people that have issues
that like just holding on to regular
reality. So I'm not suggesting
that everybody do it,
but I'm suggesting that we should
be able to go places and try it.
If you're a fucking regular person and
you've got your shit together and you
know and you,
you're,
you're curious about expanding your
mind and your consciousness with these
experiences,
there should be a place where we could
go where the government fucking make sure
this stuff is pure,
they get taxes from it.
Everybody profits and the society profits
because you're going to have better
though man. I mean it really needs to
go back to just being free. You know,
it should,
okay that would be nice,
but why not have it where you can make
money off of it and it actually is a
contributing member to society. Okay.
Because let's go back selling it,
giving people the gold coins and shit
and making, hey man, here's a basket.
Can I have some eggs?
You know what I mean?
Like we can go back to bartering things,
but in the meantime we need God
damn government. You know we need,
you know what I'm saying? I don't
know. I'm not sure about that.
There is a committee, the
government out there, there is
a myth of government, some structure.
We need to be able to call the cops.
We need someone who's going to fucking
fix the roads. Roads. We need some shit.
They say we don't help.
The problem is is when they say we don't
need any organization is kind of silly.
Well you have to say,
I don't want to give a name call out here,
but please don't check this
300 million people. Man.
You need to go to my podcast and
check out this show called the myth of
government that I did a few weeks ago.
Okay, let's talk about farts. No, no.
Shut up Brian. Shut up. I just a,
I think you know Brian's got to keep
it as shallow as possible. Yeah,
that's what he's here for.
Real.
Let's not get deep at all.
Let's, we got pretty deep dude.
That's deeper than most people.
We can't get scholarly. We can't,
we can't go drop into a thousand names.
It's just too confusing for all the
stoners and are in their car right now
called.
I'm trying to fucking absorb this man.
But the books names are important.
So the number one book from John Marco
Allegro is called the sacred mushroom and
across,
and that is the one we talked about
earlier and Jay Yawns two books that he's
published are, what was the, uh, the
mushroom one, the Holy Holy Mushrooms,
the most recent one. And
then the one before that is
astro theology in shamanism.
Christianity's pagan roots.
And that one's really interesting too
because there's so many cool photographs
in it and you can just really see, yeah,
they both have a lot of photos. Keller,
nobody would have ever believed
that shit was real. Nobody.
Will you just looking at those
photos and be like, are these mate,
I think making this up?
Like how could this be written?
And most of them we pulled
from ancient library archives,
Biblical archives and stuff.
Are you going to put them in digital form
and any of these books? Because I, I've,
I've honestly caught my selfie.
Bali mushroom book is available on kindle,
but because astro theology and shamanism
has like 185 color images and it,
it was too hard to put it into a,
a clean digital format like Kennel.
So it's left in book only for
man. I feel like we should be able
to do that in iPad form or you know,
and I got a couple of copies. I'm yeah,
iPads have that option now. I mean I,
I've been watching,
not watching but I say watching comic
books on an iPad because it is like a
watching a comic book if you've never
seen it. Well you can get iPad has um,
a bunch of different programs and one
of them is for marvel comics and you buy
comics and you can watch them
frame by frame, you tap the frame,
then it goes to the next frame and
then, oh, it's fucking incredible man.
It's incredible.
And if they can do that with comic books
and have these high resolution images
for each one,
I feel like they should be able to
do that with your magazine or your,
your book rather. Cause they, they do it
with magazines to do with wired magazine.
Yeah. This is, he's got the marvel
comics one. See how it's set up
instead of you looking at Saturday,
same people from pirating it, those,
the thing a big, because what it does,
it has to run inside of a program.
So this comic alone, you can't just
take out and look at it like got to,
you got a keyboard in
your little case studies.
He bitched keyboard you sexy bitch.
You know what you're doing.
And it doesn't even seem much bigger
than a regular iPad with keyboard is
probably
the right size.
Do you,
are you considering taking that
with you instead of a laptop? Yeah,
I've been doing that lately. But
you're living on the edge. It's only,
I can't work relate too much.
Like I can't run it podcasts on it.
No disposable media on it.
Right.
You can't like connect anything is
there a USB knows nothing. Right.
And connect the USB to it when a hard
drive or anything and you can't use it as
a hard travel can store things on
the desktop. Internet and games.
I like game boy and a new slate that's
a full on computer. You can edit audio,
do everything,
all programs
desktop. Why couldn't you create
a new file and put it on desktop?
Can you do that? I mean it really
depends on what you need to do.
Like if you want to have like a
document. Yes, there's a word program.
There's Dropbox, there's you save
them inside the the the IPAD.
It'll allows you to save things.
Yeah.
It's got a 64 gig hard drive and
really or whatever it is eventually.
Do you think that's what's
going to be going on?
If that seems like a small laptop?
I totally feel that.
Let me feel that it's still kind of
heavy. I tell you, Mac, Mac book, air,
macbook air,
they're about to release a new one.
I think next week the new macbook
airs are the way to go there.
The price of the macbook air is now
only a thousand dollars or less and and,
and that they're having a new one
that comes out next week that's,
it uses this new memory that's going to
be so much faster. Something like that.
I mean for the majority,
unless you're working heavy on the road,
that right there is better than any iPad
or tablet or anything skipped that wait
for the new Mac.
But most people just need to keep up
with whatever technology is on websites.
Right? Yeah. I mean absolutely. It's just,
it's just basic work usually speaking
to technology, aren't you the dude?
Didn't you transcribe a gang
of those? Uh, Terence Mckenna
didn't.
You
did. Right. Cause I remember
when I first met you,
you were talking about having those
from Siemens can remembers for the last
seven or eight years,
right.
Have you had to do damage control because
you know as much as he had, right.
There was a lot of pseudoscience bullshit
in there to really misinformation.
People have criticized
him for a few things.
What was the main thing that you think
that you could talk about? The 10 well,
2012 first off, I mean now we know
exactly where the whole theory came from,
where they developed it. Basically, it
originally started with a in search of,
and then a hose Eric [inaudible] and
Terence Mckenna picked up on it and they
spread it until, you know, Daniel
Pinchbeck made it famous based.
So you're talking about
the Mayan version of two,
2012 not even Terrence as TimeWave zero
and all of that was launched by Mckenna
and the in search of program with
Leonard Nimoy and Shit. That was the,
the the premier episode.
So as your assertion,
if people are,
people don't know this,
Terence Mckenna came up with a thing
called TimeWave zero novelty theory. Well,
you know, Terrence, Terrence admitted that
the knowledge, the theory was, hold on,
hold on.
It's a,
it's a theory that just as for people who
don't know what the fuck we're talking
about, all right. It's a theory that
supposedly can track waves and time.
And the idea is that time is actually
something that you can track with a
program and that his program was based
on the each ang and that it tracked
novelty or innovation and inventions and,
and,
and great moments of
change all throughout time.
And that by applying this novelty program,
this algorithm to the past,
he could point out real big spikes
in the curve. That was all bullshit.
Well, the problem was, and uh,
there was a guy who came out and
presented a paper called mathematical
hallucinations, is Watson.
Uh, I don't remember the guys,
the Watson, there was a,
there was a guy named,
I remember it's in my ans book,
but uh,
came out with a paper mathematical
hallucinations and basically showed that,
you know, what Terrence did was
arbitrarily place the, this,
the end date. And there is no
way really to match up perfectly.
He just had to arbitrarily say
December 21st, 2012 and if you look in,
what was his other options, he could have
said January 30th, 2013 he could sing,
he could have said
anything because in 1975,
when the first edition of
invisible landscape came out,
you can look in the first edition
and there is no, December 21st, 2012,
it just says 2011 or 2012.
It's in the 1993 edition when he and
Jose are Gwas got together. And, and,
and both decided on December,
December 21st, 2012 date. But in fact,
there is no,
there is no even,
there is no connection to the
Mayan calendar there whatsoever.
Well, there wasn't supposed to be
in my Mckenna Mckenna's defense.
It took him 25 years to work on this thing
well out himself and admitted that
it was wrong before his death.
What was wrong about it?
That because of the arbitrary placement,
and there was a few flaws in the math
that this guy had pointed out in the
mathematical hallucinations
paper that Mckenna, uh,
stuck to his academic honesty and
relinquished the theory. Well, this is,
my theory has continued on.
I don't understand because
you're saying that he lied.
What you're basically saying
is that he knew about that.
Well, I talked to, I talked to his
brother about this, Dennis Mckenna,
and he's been on my show and he and I
have done a couple shows together as well
on other places. But, uh,
what he said was that basically the
theory got so popular so quickly that
Terrence basically just let it
run the theory, the, the, the,
the novelty and the end date that the
entire theory is based on the appeal to
novelty, which is a logical
fallacy in and of itself.
What about the theory?
I mean,
what about the end day coinciding with
the end of the long count of the Mayan
calendar?
Well,
there is no,
see there's only one monument in that
we know of its monuments six that even
discusses December 21st,
2012 and the only thing that it
says is that a king will be robed.
That is it. Anything else that's
applied about December 21st,
2012 beyond that has been
made up and embellish.
So it might be that prince dude from
England just goes to get a new suit.
I am betting my money on.
So you know,
so anybody who says that
it's the end of the world,
that they can trace this to the Mayan
calendar, all of that stuff has made up.
The only thing,
the only that we have is a king
will be robed. Oh really?
That's amazing. That's it.
What about the end of the long count,
isn't it the end of the long count?
December 31st and January 1st it's
about, you know, that, you know,
I mean there may be a planetary alignment,
but you know,
do the polls shift and does the end of
the world happen and all of this stuff.
I mean people,
you know,
wake up in the morning and get
ready for work and you know,
take a shower and all that shit
like you usually do on December 20th
second pinch back says that we should be
in the woods and we should make our own
money. Right. Well,
Daniel Pinchbeck charges $325 a ticket
for 22 2012 conferences as well.
He really, yeah. Really?
Wow. What a genius.
He asked me to do one in like Utah.
Yeah.
Well go to you all the power to them. You
know, I know professor John Hops, who's,
uh, who's an expert in Maya's studies
and he sent pinch back a whole bunch of
information when he was writing that book,
showing that pinch,
his whole theory was completely
bogus. You know, not only that,
but Pinchbeck is using an Aztec God kits,
a Quadel to tech talk about, uh, uh,
Maya calendar.
What is an Aztec God dealing with the
Maya calendar and why would he come down
and come to Daniel Pinchbeck this
New Yorker, white guy to, you know,
to reveal 2012 to the
world, right? [inaudible]
wait a minute, wait a minute.
You say, wait a minute.
He actually says that this thing came
down and revealed it to him. Yeah.
Quadel and Aztec,
God came to him and told him about
a Mayan calendar and the 2012 thing,
the end of the community's
needs. So, you know,
I remember when I said about arguing
the arbitrary or earlier when you don't
have any evidence of anything, it's
bullshit and you throw it out. Well,
this is when you take,
are arguing the arbitrary and you make a
fucking shit load of money on. Exactly.
Okay. But this guy, he, I did
not know that he did this.
So he, I've met him before.
He seemed like a very nice conversation
with them out in my backyard. Well,
are we talked about at
the end of the world?
I think that's what he rocks with what?
I wanted to get them on the podcast,
see if I can get them high and
just dug about life, you know,
find out what makes you
tick, dude. Um, but,
so you're saying that it's all bullshit.
So you're saying that he's just,
there's no correlation to the Maya
calendar and you're saying it like it says
God Catsa Quadel was it a dream? That's
the story is a trip or whatever. Right.
Okay. And so, and so there's an Aztec
God telling him about a Maya calendar.
We're talking about two different
cultures, two different religions,
two different calendars.
The Maya didn't celebrate quests.
It's like, it's like, you know,
Jesus came to me in this vision and told
me to teach the world about the Mayan
calendar. Right. Same ridiculousness.
The Mayans didn't study quinto Quarto
or they didn't have a quite so Quadel
well, they have their own deities
in their own college model.
It's not, no, it's not called
Catsa. Quadel. That's an
asset. That's an asset. God.
Hmm. So that snake, the plumed
serpent from the Maya, what is that?
What's that called? Oh, let me see. Oh,
thank you.
Right.
I don't, I'm not recalling the
name off the top of my head. Okay,
so you're basically saying pinch and
shit though. Yes. Wow. Strong words.
You heard a Pinchbeck. It's time to come
on the podcast for counterpoint point.
Counterpoint in there and
have him address publicly.
All of John Hubs is points that ups has
been publishing the entire regions of
2012. He's published it three,
uh, two times on my show,
but he's also coming out with
a book on the whole thing.
I watched a fascinating show on them
trying to figure out how to decode Mayan
language because what Mayan language,
like each,
each little symbol like will
like you will say things like,
you will see things like
Mckenna described it.
Like if you had an eyeball and a
saw and an aunt insect and a rose,
I saw aunt rose. That's how you
would say I saw aunt rose. Right?
You'd have to do it like
that. Like it's, it's,
it's incredibly difficult to decipher,
but a fascinating documentary about these
scientists and archeologists trying to
break it down and figuring out what the
fuck everything means and how long it
took and all these breakthroughs that
they can go wrong to all sorts of things
that are being thrown. What's so
difficult to decipher? It's like,
and I was going to ask you
this because I've seen,
I saw this in a park and not a podcast,
a documentary once,
but I an Ari agreed that
it's probably correct,
but I haven't been able to break it
down with anybody who really knows a lot
about ancient, the ancient Bible
and the ancient Hebrew Bible.
The ancient Hebrew Bible, uh, was all,
that was not the earliest
version of the Bible.
The earlier versions of the Bible
where the sacred would, uh, was,
was the Dead Sea Scrolls.
Right?
Well,
the Dead Sea scrolls were probably written
from the second century BCE to about
67,
80.
Original Torah would've been written,
like genesis was probably
written about five 86 BCE.
So the Torah with, you know,
certain aspects of the Torah,
which we don't have an original
copy that's that old, but, uh,
would technically be older than certain
sections of the Dead Sea Scrolls.
But there is a lot of, you know,
identical copies of, of, uh,
original Hebrew texts
in the Dead Sea Scrolls.
And the Dead Sea scrolls were
written in Aramaic. Right.
Which they're written in Aramaic
and it's on animal skins. Right. Uh,
mostly most of it's on par parchment.
Some of it was on a pirates.
And then, uh, then there was
the copper scroll as well,
but there was someone animal skins.
Yeah, most of it was parchment,
which is lamb skin. Yeah. Oh, wow.
That's what Parchman is. Right.
Wow. I thought it was a type of
paper. I have no idea. Right. Wow.
And so that was one of the things that
I read that they were trying to match up
different pieces of the Dead Sea Scrolls
by using DNA so that the parchment came
from the same cow matching
the DNA of the fucking,
the shit they were writing on.
Try to figure out what pile this pile is.
All this one animal. Let's figure
out if this was the same scroll.
Fucking incredible Mami.
Thank you.
That is a,
that is a brilliant idea.
Did you,
um,
have you ever seen this shit that's
going on now in Turkey where they're
unveiling that that temple that was,
it was on the front page of a,
of a life magazine recently
or not in life? Um,
so it's the yellow and
national geographic. It's a
go go Beckley Tepi that uh,
it completely predates by a huge chunk.
Anything that they thought people were
doing 12,000 years ago or earlier.
It's um, you know, the earliest known
human civilizations, Mesopotamia.
It's like Babylon in Iraq.
Interesting. No, I recall hearing
something about it, but I haven't studied.
They found this is these temples in
Turkey and there they've been, uh,
unearthing I'm there trying to like
decipher them and figure out what the fuck
it is.
This is back when they thought people
were nothing but straight hunter gatherers
just roaming around like animals.
Well we're,
we're finding out more and more often
that civilization is probably 10 or 15,000
years older than most previously believed.
And a lot of those early civilizations,
they had evidence of cattle worship
and evidence of psychedelic mushrooms.
Marsha, right? Cows and
mushrooms go hand in hand. Yeah.
Like that one. Um, one of the earliest
ones. What was it? Um, uh, God,
chuck,
how do you say I'd Tuck Tuck Holyoke.
Yeah, I know what you're and
cut the line or whatever.
However you say it looks weird
when it's written it down. Right?
But it's all cows and shit.
They're worshiping counts.
I guess you would worship cast cause
they keep you alive because they eat them
and that
and then they poop. And then these,
these things that give you religious, uh,
inspiration come out of the poop.
Yeah.
That's the amazing part of it is that
most likely that's responsible for why
Hindus are so fascinated
by cows and they love it.
Oh, sure. And don't want to ever even take
that into consideration. Now, you know,
and there's more than a hundred a
hundred psychedelic psychoactive plants
dedicated to Shiva alone.
Yeah. But, uh, you know, the
Hindus still use bang or bond,
which is marijuana and Soma was argued
by Gordon Wasson to be a am Anita
miscarried,
the red and white spotted mushroom that
you see in all the fairy tales and note
with gnomes and dwarves and,
and Mario brothers and shit like that.
And there's so much ancient Hindu art.
It shows people holding up mushrooms,
mushrooms and mushrooms coming out of
their heads and all this stuff. You know,
just like we've got for, for
ancient Christian, uh, uh, artwork.
There's a lot of that stuff out there.
It's amazing that you have to hear about
this from the podcast of a comedian.
You know, you know, hearing about
this on CNN, they won't discuss this.
They wouldn't allow you to come on and
have a two hour uncensored conversation
about the origin. No kidding. Yeah, it's,
it's, it's a weird world that we live in,
man. It's a weird world that we have
this incredible access to information,
but yet we're still filtered or
filtered pretty fucking heavily.
It starting to change though.
They're really starting to change.
It blows me away too.
How many academics and researchers
are out there all over the world and
universities working on this stuff and
there's academics all over the place that
know about it. But, uh, you know,
the mainstream public is
completely unaware of it
for the longest time,
for any academic using even the term
psychedelics as a subject of serious
research, you know, you got all,
I'm looking into psychedelics,
so what the fuck are you wasting
your career on, man? You know,
the leary and the, the bad connotation
that he left a psychedelics. Yes. Yeah.
But you know,
it's interesting that time life or
that Time magazine actually had more
influence and popularizing LSD
then Tim leary had in time,
life was being run by skull and bones.
Huh? What did, how did time life
have more? Just the stories? Yeah.
Well, the Henry Luce who is the
president of timeline, if he, you know,
he's even his wife,
Clare Booth Luce is even closed.
Quoted as saying that she and her husband
had more to do with popularizing LSD
then Tim leary ever did
on purpose. Oh yeah. Wow.
There they had done it and they
were, they were, they were in on the,
on it from the top,
but Timothy leary was the spokesperson
because he was a guy like, holy shit,
this guy's a harder,
he was the one that they
put up front as the spokesperson.
He was the one that Kinda
just went hog wild with it.
Was he responsible in any way
for the Ted Kaczynski thing?
That's an interesting question.
I would have to go to a were
Ted Kaczynski is locked up and
ask him myself, you know? Yeah.
That would be an interesting guy
to do an interview with. Right.
People wouldn't be angry.
You know,
it's like when someone's
killed a member of your family,
you don't want that person
being glorified as you know.
Perhaps I misunderstood the fuck
happened. And who, who gave you the LSD?
What was behind the program? Let's
think. Let's get down to the meat.
Tell us what really happened there.
Isn't it incredible that he really
is like a true, I mean it's possible.
We don't know whether or not that's
what caused him, but it's possible.
It's a very strong possibility that he
really has some real Manchurian candidate
Kennedy type of a dude. He really is
something guy that they, you know, they,
they did some shit to him. Not as
my AdvaMed is that, you know what?
I think he might've been more
brilliant than that. But yeah, I don't,
I mean the idea that someone
could be changed and then
become a killer, you know,
and that literally it can be done not in
miniature and candidate was like he was,
what did they,
you have to come up to him
and say something to him
and he fucking snaps or some
silliness like that.
But I think the,
in the case of Kandinsky that they
might have fried disguise circuit point.
This is the,
but I don't think it was planned.
Did all the unibomber shit 20 or 25
years after these LSD experiments.
You know, he was a really, oh yeah.
You know that those experiments were
in the what, the 50s or 60s and a,
he was professor of math up until
mid nineties up at Berkeley.
Really? So when, um, didn't need what?
I thought it was only a professor for
a few years, but I don't think so.
Check double check me. Do it. Pretty
sure I do a wiki search. In fact,
check me shit.
This is going to take too much time,
but let's just say then just the net
is a very fascinating documentary.
If you want to watch it, it is a from
another country, I'm not sure which show.
It's all in subtitles. And
you know, there's another
really good documentary that people should
check out is called the crazy rulers
of the world. It's a that they, the,
the movie the Hollywood movie men who
stare at goats is based off of the film.
Crazy rulers of the world. Check out
that one and the net back to back.
It'll give you some really
interesting insights.
Information on us.
Intelligence and psychedelics do is too
much information out there and I don't
want some of it in my head yonder oven.
I don't touch shit.
Let you get into it then.
Don't you think though that a certain
point in time it's like God dammit.
You're like, no, no, no.
But I'm saying dig so deep into the
rabbit hole and he's like, fuck,
I can never like live a real life.
Now I'm always looking for a skull and
crossbones and secret societies and
fucking anybody can look in an
old dictionary and see that uh,
the Illuminati in skull and bones and shit
is real. I mean pull up, pull out, uh,
a 1911 dictionary and that Shit's
right there. Nobody disputes. Oh, sure.
I hear people. Oh, the Illuminati
conspiracy. But that's shit.
It's totally approved.
That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is it has ever get to
a point in time where you're just like,
you're, you're so absorbed in all the
shit that you can enjoy regular life.
Not really. I mean I, I'm
fascinated by this research.
That's why I do it in the first
place. It's a passion. Right.
And wouldn't do it if I wasn't fascinated
by it. Yeah. And it's, but you're,
your research is all like exposing all
kinds of crazy shit that the government
is up to.
I mean,
it's like founding the founding father
of the whole field of psychedelics was
the chairman for the council
on Foreign Relations. I mean,
when that shit goes public out there in
our field, it's going to be explosive.
I mean, you know, that's taking away
their guy who was the founding father,
but I can show that he,
he stole many of his ideas from this
other researcher who came 70 years before
him and the 1890s. And uh, but you know,
there's a whole big there. You know,
there's, there's scandal on top of scandal
on top of intelligence, CIA bullshit.
And does it ever get to a point where
you're like overwhelmed by this shit when
you just want to just take a deep breath?
Do you have your phone shit on silly boy,
you know, every once in a while. Sure.
But, uh, you know, usually when I get
into and find all the more crazy shit,
it's like, Aha, here's another book.
Write another book for you to write or
to read or to write. Oh, well, okay.
In that sense, man, it
totally makes sense. What,
what the fuck can be done in closing?
What can be done? How can, how can people,
um, do something about this
situation that we're in,
that's been here since you and I were
children and that he is here now that we
have the best, the best thing
that people can do, in my opinion,
that is the real solution is pick up
the trivium pickup critical thinking,
grammar, logic and rhetoric.
That is the best way.
It's like installing a mental antivirus
system into your brain so that you know,
suddenly it's like taking the red pill.
All of a sudden the green lines are
coming down the screen. You see,
you got to write a book about this.
Um, we've, we've talked about it.
A friend of mine is already
writing a book on it.
We've done a number of documentaries
on the trivia run trivium education.com
website that people can check out and
run this. I run that website. Yeah.
So people can check that out.
There's,
there's videos and stuff up there
that people can check out on it.
But I would say that that's
the most important thing
because once you have that,
you can see all the other bullshit
going on it teeth, you know you,
it doesn't teach you what to think.
It teaches you how to think
and how to see through all that
bullshit. That's nice for the people
that are going to pay attention,
but what kind of a strategy,
if any,
is possible for letting people
know about psychedelics,
letting people know about the benefits
and positives of these things that have
really been held back from people.
One of the things that Mckenna said that
always stuck with me is that living a
life and going birth to the grave with
like without psychedelics to me is like
living a life and going birth to
the grave without ever having sex.
I would agree with that,
but the problem with just
doing psychedelics with how
critical thinking is that
when somebody breaks free
of their religious paradigm
or the new age paradigms
that are just as much mine control out
there as anything else. The problem is,
is if they do psychedelics alone,
they're easily manipulated.
And so I disagree with,
with Mckenna and Larry's theory
that everybody should just take it.
I think that people should be given the
proper tools of critical thinking and
then take the psychedelics and
then they really break free.
Basically we have to start our
own cult slash educational center.
Oh, we don't need it.
When do we need to do,
that's the nice thing about the trivium
is that it prevents people from buying
into religious creek.
Clearly not serious,
but if we had it called,
where would we rock this shit salt
and see Brian Canoga Park Canoga Park.
It's really close by.
It'd be much more convenient.
There's no lesson exposing people to
this information is probably step one.
There's a bunch of people that are
growing up now that are in high school and
college that are reading these types of
books and listening to these types of
conversations that we're having on this
podcast and researching this type of
information. And uh, just having this
stuff, being a part of public discourse,
it allows people to know it's out there.
And it allows people to start thinking
about things and a little bit of a
different way, you know, we're all
programmed in one way or another,
whether we like it or not,
you know,
we're programmed by our experiences were
programmed by our environment and um,
it's not always necessarily for your own
good to follow that fucking programming.
Right.
Indeed.
And so Jaan thank you very much for
coming on the show and thank you for your
books man. And thank you for republishing
the Sacred Mushroom that cross.
And if people want to buy your books,
they're all available on amazon.com right?
Uh, yes, there is that where it, is there
some hippy fucking thing about Amazon?
Am I supposed to avoid it?
No, actually, but if you,
if you do buy it directly from
the gnostic media websites,
a Amazon takes less of our cuts.
So get it from me ever sponsored,
you know,
all of the research and work
is sponsored by the public.
So this a Friday, Saturday and Sunday
we will be at the Irvine Improv.
Tomorrow we're going to have an
early podcasts, a noon one with none.
Only the Duncan Trussell. Um,
so upcoming in the future.
I'm still trying to work out
this Anthony Bordain thing.
Don't block who mark Marin's
step bitch.
And uh,
I'm also going to work out a sucralose
and we're trying to get dice clay to dice.
Clay said he would do it too, but
yeah. All right, Holler at your boy.
I'll see you guys tomorrow at noon
and thank you very much and I love you
bitches.
And did Joe Rogan experience podcast
is sponsored by the flesh lie.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click
on the link for the ins fear factor,
but enough fuck with my fleshlight
endorsement. Never thought of that,
that they might,
they might step in with
some fucking shitty letter
writing campaign. Don't do it.
Pitches. I liked that job. Paid.
Jenna Hayes has a flashlight.
What we're going to do,
goodnight. Go to Joe Joe,
Joe rogan.net and click on the link for
the fleshlight error in the code name
Brogan, and you get 15% off. Okay. We
love you. You love us, and we'll be
back, Neda. Bye Bye.